OF THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEES WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
BETTER MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY AND ACTUALLY I DON'T
SEE ANY ON THE SCREEN. I AM
JOINED IN THE SENATE CHAMBER BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW CHAIR OF
THE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE AND
MEMBERS OF BOTH COMMITTEES. WE
ALSO HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
AS A REMINDER PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASKED THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THE TO USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING OUR IT
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU WERE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE. YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEES. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
HEARING ROOMS IN THE SENATE
GALLERY TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE UBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE OR ONE FOUR
ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE ZERO ZERO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE.
WEBSITE OR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S HEARING
PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE PROVIDED
UPON THE CONCLUSION OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA'S
PRESENTATION AND FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
TWO COMMITTEES. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER THISCAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE UN MUTED. AND
YOU WILL NOW BE READY OR THEN
BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEES. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND IN THAT REGARD IT
IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
SPEAK CLEARLY AND THAT YOU
SPEAK LOUDLY. AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING A
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS. WHO WERE
ADJUSTING TO NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES LEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES MAY BE
HEARD. SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS LIKE TODAY'S ALLOW FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF REGULATORY
PROGRAMS AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CHANGES IN THE LAW
ORLOFF RATIONS ARE FUNCTIONS
ARE NECESSARY TODAY'S HEARING
IS THE SECOND IN A SERIES OF
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. TO ASSIST
IN THE REVIEW AND EVALUATION OF
THE BOARD. COMMITTEE STAFF
PREPARED A BACKGROUND PAPER
WHICH IDENTIFIES ISSUES AND
MAKE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THE BOARD THIS PAPER HAS BEEN
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AND MADE AVAILABLE TO
INTERESTED PARTIES. TODAY'S
HEARING WILL FOCUS ON VARIOUS
ISSUES REGARDING THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA OTHER THAN
ENFORCEMENT ISSUES WHICH WERE
COVERED DURING OUR FIRST
HEARING WITH RESPECT TO THE
BOARD. IN THAT REGARD THE
MEDICAL BOARD WILL PROVIDE A
VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
VARIOUS FUNCTIONS MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEES WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE ANY OTHER
ISSUES OR QUESTIONS THAT THEY
MAY HAVE. WE WILL ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
CONSUMER GROUPS PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. AT THIS POINT
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE MY
DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUE IN MY
PARTNER IN THIS EFFORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EVAN LOW CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. TO MAKE
ANY OPENING REMARKS HE MAY WISH
TO MAKE SURE LOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIR ROTH OF. BUT
ONE AGAIN ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD
WORK OF YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL AS YOUR DEDICATION TO
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE A
PHENOMENAL APPROACH TO. MAKING
SURE THAT WE FOCUS ON THE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I ALSO WANT
TO TAKE OF AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WELCOME DR A KILO WEBER TO THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE HE IS ALSO JOINING US
HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE HEARING
AS THE- OVER FOR THIS OVERSIGHT
TO UNCENSORED HEARING AND
LOOKING FOR TO THAT DISCUSSION
AHEAD OF US. DR WEBER WELCOME
THANK YOU CHIRLA. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR SPEAKERS I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE THOSE MEMBERS OF
THE PBLIC WHO WISH TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE OR ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT
FIVE. WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE
THE ACCESS CODE. SIX FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE ZERO ZERO. WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM CRISTINA LAWSON
PRESIDENT OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA MS LAWSON. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED RAS AND SHARE
LOW AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ALL AGAIN THIS
MORNING- TO BEGIN MY REMARKS I
OF COURSE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS HAD
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND EXPRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
ENTIRE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA OUR DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR CALIFORNIA'S
ESSENTIAL AND FRONTLINE WORKERS
INCLUDING THOSE OF OURSE ARE
REGULATED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO
INCLUDING THOSE IN ALLIED
HEALTH PROFESSIONS- AND AGAIN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO HAVE
DEDICATED THEIR TIME AND THEIR
ENERGY- AND IN MANY CASES REST
THEIR LIVES- TO PROTECT HOURS.
WITH ME TODAY FROM THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IS DR
HOWARD KRAUSS OUR BOARD VICE
PRESIDENTS AT BILL PACIFICA OUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR REGGIE VERY
GEEZ ARE DEPUTY DIRECTOR TERRY
WEBB OUR STAFF COUNSEL MARINO
CONNOR OUR CHIEF OF LICENSING
AND JANET JONES OUR CHIEF OF
ENFORCEMENT WE GET TO QUESTIONS
ALL OF US WILL BE HAPPY. TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE ABOUT. I COURSE
CONSUMER PROTECTION IS THE
BOARD'S HIGHEST PRIORITY AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
THE SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS
PROVIDES FOR US TO DISCUSS OUR
MISSION WITH ALL OF YOU. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO GOING THROUGH
THE TOPICS THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
TIME TO GET TO DURING OUR PRIOR
HEARING. ONE AREA OF PRIMARY
CONCERN FOR THE BOARD THIS YEAR
IT'S RIGHT TO REGAIN SOLID
FINANCIAL FOOTING. THE BOARD'S
REVENUES AND EXPENDITURES ARE
GREATLY IMBALANCED AND THAT IS
WHY THIS YEAR WERE SEEKING A
FEE INCREASE WHICH WOULD BE THE
FIRST SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN
THE FEE AMOUNTS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX. THE BOARD
RECOGNIZES THE CONCERNS THAT
MAY COME ABOUT WITH THE SIZE OF
THE FEE INCREASE THATWE ARE
SEEKING AND WE HOPE TO HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE SO
THAT WE MAY CAN. CONTINUE AND
ADVANCING OUR CONSUMER
PROTECTION MISSION. THIS IS WHY
WE'RE ALSO COMMITTED TO FINDING
NEW WAYS TO ACHIEVE COST
SAVINGS AND NEW EFFICIENCIES.
ONE WAY IS THROUGH THE BOARD'S
LICENSING PROCESS WHICH WE WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING ABOUT
TODAY. AS WE ARE REVIEWING HOW
WE CAN REDUCE OUR PERHAPS EVEN
ELIMINATE PAPER FROM OUR
INITIAL APPLICATION AND LICENSE
RENEWAL PROCESS THESE. OUR
STAFF OF IDENTIFIED CERTAIN
STATUTES THAT REQUIRE THE USE
OF PAPER. WE HOPE TO SEE THESE
AMENDED THROUGH THIS PROCESS
THAT WE CAN HAVE ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY IN OUR LICENSING
PROCESS. COURSE THE CODED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS ALSO
ACCELERATED OUR EFFORTS TO
DEVELOP A MORE FLEXIBLE WORK
ENVIRONMENT AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO ADOPTING NEW EFFICIENCIES
THERE WHEN THEY ARE IDENTIFIED.
WITH THAT CHAIRMAN WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU WERE CHAIR
LOW HAVE OR TO ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK
YOU MS LAWSON UP LET'S TURN TO.
MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE
FLOOR. ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE TWO
COMMITTEES. FOR THE BOARD
MEMBERS OR BOARD STAFF
INCLUDING MS LAWSON PERHAPS
STARTING WITH MY- DISTINGUISHED
COLLEAGUES SHARE LOW. HE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUATION OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE HAD IN
THE PREVIOUS DISCUSSIONS AND
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO
HAVE SUBSEQUENT CONVERSATIONS
ONE OF ONE TWO BUT I WANTED OF
POSE A QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO
FEE INCREASES- TO- MISTER PER
FISCAL. SINCE YOU HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE OVER AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE HAS THE BORDER
DIGNIFIED ANY OPERATIONAL
EFFICIENCIES- EITHER IN
LICENSING OR ENFORCEMENT THAT
MAY HAVE AFFECTED OR IMPACTED
THE NEED FOR A FEE INCREASE
SPECIFICALLY. YES WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE QUESTION
I CAN ASSURE YOU FROM THE TIME
THAT I FIRST STARTED OBVIOUSLY
ARE THE FISCAL ISSUE WAS OF
UTTER PRIORITY AND SO WE HAVE
TO LOOK FOR EFFICIENCIES. AS
HAS BEEN EXPLAINED
APPROXIMATELY 80% OF THE
RESOURCES OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
ARE DEVOTED TO ENFORCEMENT AND
THEREFORE OPERATING ENFORCEMENT
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND MORE
EFFECTIVELY. IS AN ABSOLUTE
PRIORITY WHAT WE HAVE DONE
SINCE THE TIME THAT I HAVE BEEN
HERE IS WE HAVE INVESTED MORE
IN REVIEW OF COMPLAINTS AT THE
EARLIEST STAGES. TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY TRIAGE AND MAY THE
COMPLAINTS. ARE AND THIS
INCLUDES A VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
MEDICAL REVIEW OF CASE. WHERE
IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCE IT HAS
OBVIATED THE NEED FOR CASES TO
GO TO FURTHER INVESTIGATION
WHEN THERE IS AN INITIAL
DETERMINATION THAT THERE IS NO
DEPARTURE FROM THE STANDARD OF
CARE. FURTHERMORE IT'S THE
EFFECTIVE MANAGEMENT OF THESE
CASES WHICH WILL AT THE END
DELIVER MORE EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT AND MORE EFFICIENT
ENFORCEMENT. SINCE THE TIME
THAT I'VE BEEN IN THE POSITION
THE TOTAL NUMBERS OF CASES
WITHIN THE COMPLAINTS SYSTEM.
HAS DECREASED BY APPROXIMATELY
10% NOW THE MOST MPORTANT
THING IS FOR EACH CASE TO BE
DEALT WITH APPROPRIATELY THERE
WILL BE SOME CASES THAT REQUIRE
MORE RESOURCES. AND WILL
REQUIRE- OF THE ABSOLUTE
DEDICATION TO COME TO A
SUCCESSFUL CONCLUSION TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC BUT WHERE
IT'S POSSIBLE WERE CASES ARE
LESS SERIOUS BUT THERE IS NO
ISSUE OF FITNESS TO PRACTISE IF
WE CAN DEAL WITH THOSE
EFFECTIVELY. AT AN EARLY STAGE
THAT WILL BOTH PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND BE COST EFFECTIVE SO
THAT IS ONE AREA OF SAVINGS
THERE'S ANOTHER AREA OF SAVINGS
IN TERMS OF. MAKING OUR
LICENSING PROCESSES MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT WITH THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY. WE'VE MADE MAJOR
ADVANCES IN TERMS OF DOING OUR
REVIEWS OF ORIGINAL
DOCUMENTATION ONLINE WE PARTNER
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY USE THE DOCKS PORTAL.
AND THIS IS A WAY TO DO OUR JOB
MORE EFFECTIVELY MORE
EFFICIENTLY WITHOUT ANY
DIMINISH THE QUALITY. FINALLY
AS IN PARALLEL WITH OTHER STATE
BODIES WE HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
DELIVER FURTHER SAVINGS. AND SO
WE HAVE UNDERTAKEN A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF ALL OUR
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES WE
HAVE REALIZE SOME SAVINGS WOULD
BE HAPPY TO GIVE YOU DETAILS OF
THAT. NOW AS A RESULT OF ALL OF
THAT I CAN SAY THAT THE FIFTH
FINANCIAL PROJECTIONS THAT WERE
DELIVERED. IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY AT THE TIME THAT THE FEE
INCREASE. WAS SOUGHT THEY HAVE
IMPROVED BUT I MUST SAY
IMPROVED MARGINALLY IT WAS
ANTICIPATED. THAT WE WOULD BE
AND DEFICIT POSITION IN THE
CURRENT FINANCIAL YEAR. THAT IS
NO LONGER ANTICIPATED TO BE THE
CASE BUT STILL THERE IS A
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE WHICH WE
HAVE. AND THAT CANNOT BE
RECTIFIED BY THE CURRENT
SAVINGS REALIZED IF YOU WOULD
LIKE MORE DETAIL IN TERMS OF
OUR FUTURE SAVINGS I COULD TURN
IT OVER TO OUR DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. MARQUISE PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF TWO X. SOME
DETAIL OF ALL THE ACHIEVING
THAT WE ACCOMPLISHED SO ALL
LIKE MUST PRESS AND THIS ONLY
AMOUNT TO ABOUT PER OF OUR OP
AND SOME OF THIS IS- BABY IN
ANY ANY ANY BILL ENTITY THAT
YOU WOULD- UNDERTAKE AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE CHEATED
THROUGH ABOUT NOVEMBER JANUARY-
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY AND
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR THIS IS A
LIST OF ITEMS THAT WE WERE
SUCCESSFULLY ABLE TO IMPLEMENT.
AND BASICALLY WE LOOKED AT THE
OPERATIONS TOP DOWN NOT JUST
FOCUSING ON ANYONE UNIT LIKE
LICENSING OR ENFORCEMENT BUT
EVERY ASPECT OF THE WORLD'S
OPERATION SO IN IN DOING SO WE
WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY AREAS
LIKE WE WERE- STILL PRACTICING
SOME OF BURNING THE DVDS AND
UTILIZE SAYING OVERNIGHT
MAILINGS OF MATERIALS TO OTHER
AGENCIES THAT WE HAVE TO
COOPERATE BUT FOR ENFORCEMENT
ASPECTS WILL SO WE PUT A STOP
TO THAT AND- START UTILIZING
ONLINE CLOUD BASIS EXCHANGE OF
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION. AND
ALSO- ELECTRONIC TRANSMISSION
OF OTHER MAILINGS THAT WE COULD
ELECTRONICALLY TRANSFERRED
WHEREVER WE CAN AND ALSO WE TOP
DOWN EVERY DEPARTMENT EVERY
STAFF MEMBER EVERY UNIT EVERY
DIVISION ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY
PRINTING UP DOCUMENTS AND ALSO
WE TELEWORKING OF COURSE LEVELS
AT BY PRODUCT OF KUWAIT BUT WE
WERE ABLE TO UTILIZED TO THE
MAXIMUM BY- ENABLING OUR STAFF
TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE 100% OF
THEIR OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCY
THROUGH TELEWORKING ELIMINATING
THE NEED FOR HER TO COME INTO
THE OFFICE SCAN AND PRINT OR
COPY FILES AND TAKE IT WITH THE
WE WERE ABLE TO GIVE THEM
ACCESS TO THEIR DOCUMENTS
ONLINE. AND ALSO. ANOTHER AREA
OF IMPROVEMENT BE MADE IN COST
SAVINGS WAS IN THE PRINTERS
SCANNER. AND RELATED SO. CONTRA
IN ACROSS ALL- THE METAL BOARD
AND WE ALSO USE OUR USE MORE
AND MORE OF SHE- SITES REDUCE
COSTS. ENSURING THE BETWEEN THE
MEMBER. UTILIZING BY. TEAMS OUR
SIR WERE. WAITING IN MAY. WAS A
HUGE A FOR A- AT I MENTION
STUFF CALL BE INDUSTRY MAIL AND
SCAN AND- TO STAFF MEMBERS- AND
ALSO- BE ONE OF THE MAJOR
SAVINGS WE WILL ACHIEVE IT WERE
WE WERE ABLE TO. WELL STOP THE
BOARD'S NEW. AND PUBLISHING IT
ON THE AND ALSO. IT BY. MEANS
ANOTHER CALL SAVING AREA WAS IN
IF. THIS LICENSE MEETS AND ONLY
RENEW FOR WITH OUR APPS NO.
ALMOST THESE SOME OF THE
SAVINGS ARE ABLE TO ACHIEVE IN
THE IN THE SHORT. IN ABOUT NINE
TEN MY- GOING. BUT THERE ARE
KERN WE ARE WE HAVE STOP IN
LOOKING INTO IMPROVING. AND
MAKING THIS A OR- SO CURRENTLY
WORK PRO HARD IN THE AREA SAW
IN A- WALLET. THAT WERE. EXT
PRINTER PLASTIC COURT THAT ARE
AT DISTRIBUTED BY. TO ALL THE
LICENSE. AND THIS FOR IS KERN-
WORK IN PROGRESS PROJECTED TO
COMPLETE MY END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. AND ALSO WE ARE
LOOKING INTO STARTING A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR DIGITAL SIGNATURE
TECHNOLOGY. ON CERTAIN BOARDS
FORMS DOUBLE ELIMINATE- SUCH A
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT FOR A
NOTARY AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO
THERE'S A PILOT PROGRAM- AT
THIS POINT BUT- THEY'RE ALSO
THE PROJECTS THAT WE WOULD NEED
YOUR SUPPORT. AND YOUR APPROVAL
IN THE AREAS OF ST CHANGE
INSPECTION THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO EVEN ACHIEVE GREATER
EFFICIENCY AND COST IMPROVEMENT
M. A. N- CONVERTING OUR RENEWAL.
AND ONLINE. PROCESS TO MOVE
AWAY FROM TRADITIONAL PAPER SO
I WOULD STOP THEIR AN ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU AS KNOW WE'RE SENSE
TO A FEE SPECIFIC NOT TO ON
THIS BOY BUT AMONGST THE OF
CONSUMER. THIS AS WE A LOOK AT
THE SUNSET AND IS V. .COM OUT
OF THE- COPA PENNED SO KNOW
THAT YOU SHARE THAT SAME TYPE
OF COMMITMENT ENSURING THAT
TYPE OF EFFICIENCIES THAT WE
HAVE AND I HOPE THAT. ARE COMEY
SAID CAN WORK WITH YOU TO
FURTHER FLESH OUT SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES AND THEN THE FIVE
FINALLY BEFORE PER TURN OVER TO
THE- REST OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS NOW THEN PIVOTING TO THAT OF
THE POST GRADUATE TRAINING
LICENSES- ONE OF THE ISSUES.
WITH RESPECT TO THE DETAIL
RELATES TO THAT OF THE BILITY
OF PHYSICIANS TO OBTAIN A
FEDERAL TAX WAIVER TO PRESCRIBE
MEDICATION USED TO TREAT THE
OPIOID ADDICTIONS AS YOU WELL
KNOW- AND- I UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME OF THESE OTHER STATES HAVE
NOT ENCOUNTERED THE SAME TYPE
OF ISSUES. THAT WE HAVE WOULD
YOU BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO SOME OF
THE DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN THAT.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIANS SOME
OF THESE OTHER STATES. YES SIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'LL BE HAPPY
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. WITH
THE INTRODUCTION OF THE PTO
LICENSE A CALIFORNIANS PRODUCED
A THREE YEAR TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS. AND OF COURSE AS
YOU'VE NOTED THERE ARE OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE THE SIMILAR.
TYPES OF REQUIREMENTS. ONCE
THAT THEY'RE ABOUT TO TEN
FIFTEEN THAT WE'VE IDENTIFED
THEY INCLUDE NEVADA- ARIZONA
MASSACHUSETTS PENNSYLVANIA. NEW
YORK OR AGAIN. AND OTHERS AND
WHAT HAS HAPPENED AS YOU WOULD
BE AWARE IS THAT THERE HAVE
WE'VE ENCOUNTERED CERTAIN
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WITH
SOME THIRD PARTIES THEY INCLUDE
MEDICAL IN TERMS OF. A
REIMBURSEMENT- FOR MOONLIGHTING
WE HAD AN ISSUE WITH SOME
AGENCIES IN TERMS OF SIGNING
DEATH CERTIFICATES WE'VE HAD
OTHERS AS YOU SAID IN TERMS OF
THE X. WAIVER. ISSUE WE HAVE
REACHED OUT. TO THESE OTHER
STATES- TO NEVADA AND FROM OUR
PRELIMINARY DISCUSSIONS HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
SIMILAR PROBLEMS WITH THAT. WE
ARE ENGAGING AT EVERY LEVEL TO
COME TO SOME SOLUTION TO SOME
OF THESE AREAS WE HAVE REACHED
OUT TO STAKEHOLDERS TO THE F.
S. M. B. N. TO OTHER AGENCIES.
ARE FOR EXAMPLE A MAYBE ONE
AREA WHICH IS OF GREAT CONCERN
IS THE ISSUE OF X. WAIVERS AND
I WOULD LIKE MY A COLLEAGUE
MARINO CONNOR HEAD OF
LICENSING. TO INDICATE WHAT
WHAT THE WORK WE'VE BEEN DOING
THERE TO TRY TO RESOLVE THE
ISSUE. HI YES- WE DID MEET WITH
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ADMINISTRATION
TO DISCUSS SOME OF THE ISSUES
WITH. DETAILS OBTAINING TAX
WAIVERS AND WE DID HAVE GOOD
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE GONE BACK AND
FORTH WITH THEM. ON A COUPLE OF
TIMES TO EXPLAIN. WHAT OUR LAW
ALLOWS. US TO DO IN THEIR SCOPE
PRACTICE- YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO WORK WITH THEM AND
FIGURE OUT. WHAT THE CENTRAL
ISSUE IS- AND IF WE CAN WORK
AROUND IT- SO WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSIONS
WITH THEM- ON THE X. WAIVER
ISSUE- BUT THAT CURRENTLY JUST
TO. POINT OUT- OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IF YOU
TELL HOLDER CAN BE ISSUED A
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE PERMIT
ONCE THE ANTENNA PTL BUT THE
ISSUE IS ATTAINING B. THE EX
WEBER SPECIFICALLY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- CARILLO DR ARAMBULA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE
COMMENTS OF OUR CHAIR FROM
ASSEMBLY BNP I'D LIKE TO ALSO
ASK ABOUT THE POSTDOCTORAL
TRAINING LICENSEES IF I MAY I'D
LIKE TO FIRST STATE THAT OUR
MEDICALSYSTEM HAS BEEN UNDER
TREMENDOUS STRAIN OVER THE PAST
YEAR MANY OF US MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE COME FROM
AREAS THAT STRUGGLE TO HAVE
ENOUGH PROVIDERS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND YET WE MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT PART OF THE
STRAIN MAY BE DUE TO THE
INABILITY OF OUR POSTDOCTORAL
TRAINING LICENSEES FROM BEEN
BILLING MEDICAL FEE FOR SERVICE
WHILE MOONLIGHTING. MANY OF OUR
POOREST COMMUNITIES MANY OF
THEM THAT I REPRESENT. MEDICAL
AND IF WE ARE SHUTTING OFF ONE
AVENUE FOR ACCESS TO CARE WE
ONLY BROUGHT IN THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THIS
SEEMS LIKE AN ISSUE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD QUICKLY FIX
THE OPEN UP SERVICES. IF YOU
COULD DOCTOR LAWSON AND MISTER
PLUS HE FORGOT WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO PROVIDE THE BOARD'S
PERCEPTION OF THE P. L. T.
RESTRICTED STATUS FOR
MOONLIGHTING. AND WHETHER YOU
THINK THE LEGISLATURE REMEDY
WOULD BE THE ONLY COURSE OF
ACTION TO RECTIFY THE SITUATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION AND CERTAINLY THE PTO
LICENSES- THE ACCESSIBILITY IS
AN ABSOLUTE PRIORITY FOR THE
BOARD ONE OF THE WHOLE REASON
SUPPORT THE PTL IN THE FIRST
PLACE. JUST TO REMIND EVERYONE
WAS TO INCREASE ACCESSIBILITY
BECAUSE WITH AN INTRODUCTION OF
THE P. T. L. WE NOW HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE. OF THE
LICENSEES FROM OTHER MEDICAL
SCHOOLS WHICH WE NEVER HAD
BEFORE WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
DEDICATED TO SOLVING THE
PROBLEM. WE ARE MEETING WITH%
ALL THE RELEVANT OFFICIALS. AND
THERE WILL UNDOUBTEDLY BE
POSSIBLE FOR A SOLUTION TO BE
REACHED. WE HAVE TO LOOK OUT TO
OTHER PRESIDENTS WHAT OTHER
STATES ARE DOING. WE WILL DO
THAT. IF NOTHING OF COURSE WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT THERE BE A
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE IF
NECESSARY. BUT WE THINK THAT WE
NEED TO FURTHER EXPLORE THE
ISSUE THERE MAY BE THINGS THAT
WE COULD DO ADMINISTRATIVELY I
MEAN AFFECTED LATE IF YOU TAKE
A STEP BACK. IF YOU LOOK AT
WHAT THESE DOCTORS ARE DOING IF
YOU LOOK AT THE TRAINING THAT
THEY HAVE RECEIVED. THERE IS NO
INCREASED RISK TO THE PUBLIC.
THAT WOULD IN ANY WAY JUSTIFY
THEM NOT BEING REIMBURSED FOR
WORK THAT PREVIOUS GENERATIONS
OF THESE LICENSEES HAVE BEEN
DOING. IF ANYTHING I WOULD
ARGUE THERE IS GREATER PRESSURE
PUBLIC PROTECTION BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOW FORMALLY WITHIN A
PROGRAM IN THE PROGRAM
DIRECTORS FOR APPROVAL WHICH WE
THINK IS A VERY GOOD SAFEGUARD.
BUT WE'RE ABSOLUTE DEAD. TO
WORKING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
WE HOPE LEGISLATION IS NOT
REQUIRED. BUT IF WE REACH THAT
DETERMINATION WE WILL BE VERY
HAPPY TO ROLE IN IT TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO ASSISTED
AND PERHAPS- PRESIDENT LAWSON
WOULD LIKE TO. ADD TO THAT. I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO AGREE WITH
THOSE COMMENTS- EXECUTIVE
OFFICER PACIFICA- AND- ALSO A
SURE- DOCTOR ARAMBULA THAT THE
MEDICAL BOARD IS COMMITTED TO
THESE ISSUES THE MEDICAL BOARD-
WILL BE MEETING ON MAY
THIRTEENTH AND MAY FOURTEENTH
AS A BOARD AND I. EXPECT THIS
TO BE A TOPIC OF OUR
CONVERSATION THERE AS WELL. I
WANNA DIG INTO ONE OF THE
POINTS THOUGH THAT HAPPENED MR
PACIFICA HAD MENTIONED WHICH IS
THERE'S NO RISK TO THE PUBLIC I
THINK THE QUESTION I HAVE IS A
FOR DECREASING ACCESS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO RECEIVE SERVICES. IF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE NOT ABLE
TO SEE DOCTORS. BECAUSE THEY
ARE UNABLE TO BUILD FOR FEE FOR
SERVICE IS THAT NOT A RISK TO
THE PUBLIC. NO I BE JUST TO
CLARIFY WHAT I WAS REFERRING TO
WAS THE WRIST FROM THE POINT OF
VIEW OF MEDIC COW. MEDIC COW
ARE SAYING THAT THEY DON'T WANT
TO PAY THESE LICENSE THESE
DOCTORS BECAUSE SOMEHOW THAT
THEY ARE ON A RESTRICTED
LICENSE. AND THEREFORE LESS
ABLE TO PRACTICE I THINK THAT
IS WRONG SO I WAS REFERRING TO
THE REST FROM THE POINT OF
MEDICARE. I ABSOLUTELY ACCEPT
THE FACT THAT IF THERE'S ANY
DEVIATION OF IN SERVICE THAT IS
A HUGE PROBLEM. AND WE ARE
DEDICATED TO RESOLVING ISSUES
OF LICENSEE IN WAYS. THAT
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF ACCESS.
ASK FOR THIS. THIS IS OUR
KRAUSS- WHAT YOU'RE GRADUATE
MEDICAL AT WHICH ALL RIGHT FOR.
IT'S KNOWLEDGE IS THAT
MOONLIGHTING A SIX SO LONG IT
IS WITH AS IT IS WITH THE
PERMISSION OF THE RESIDENCY
PROGRAM I AM EVEN DURING
MOONLIGHTING HOURS RESIDENTS IN
TRAINING ARE STILL. UNDER
SUPERVISION BY THEIR RESIDENCY
PROGRAM. THERE IS NEITHER
INTENT NOR DESIRE ON THE PART
OF THE BOARD BUT TO STOP
MOONLIGHTING. I AND I AGREE DR
ARAMBULA THAT MOONLIGHTING HAS
BEEN AN IMPORTANT SERVICE OR
HAS HELPED PROVIDE IMPORTANT
SERVICE TO UNDERSERVED AREAS.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT WE ALWAYS
ARE FACED WITH UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN THIS PROBLEM
WAS CERTAINLY NOT INTENDED WHEN
LEGISLATION WAS DRAFTED TO SEE
THREE YEARS OF POST GRADUATE
EDUCATION PRIOR TO LICENSURE
AND AS MR PERCEIVED TO HAS SAID.
WE ARE ACTIVELY REACHING OUT TO
THE TEN TO FIFTEEN OTHER STATES
THAT ALSO REQUIRE MORE THAN ONE
POSTGRADUATE. TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY HAVE FACED THE SAME
PROBLEM. SO WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A FIXABLE PROBLEM- BUT
WE'VE JUST BEGUN TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN TERMS OF
ULTIMATELY DETERMINING WHAT THE
SOLUTION MAY BE- AND WE DON'T
KNOW YET DEFERRED LEGISLATIVE
ACTION MAY BE REQUIRED- BUT IT
IS OUR INTENT. TO ALLOW
MOONLIGHTING TO CONTINUE AS IT
HAS SO THAT THERE IS NO
INTERRUPTION OF MEDICAL
SERVICE. THANK YOU THANK YOU DR
KRAUSE AND THEN IF I CAN I'D
LIKE TO ECHO OF OUR FOR
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR BROWN SAYS
THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING IN
SERVICE FOR AS LONG AS HE HAS
IS HE HAD A CHANCE TO FIX SOME
OF THE MISTAKES HE MADE WHILE
IN SERVICE. I THINK WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE
UPON THE LEGISLATION THAT THIS
BODY HAS WORKED ON AND WE MUST
BE RECEPTIVE TO WHAT MANY OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES ARE SAYING.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE LOWER
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS OR MEDICAL
ASSOCIATIONS WHO ARE SPEAKING
ABOUT THE NEED FOR US TO MEET
THIS CRISIS HEAD ON. P. AND
WOULD ASK THIS- ESTES COMMITTEE
TO MAKE SURE WE ARE SPENDING
THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO ADDRESS
IT. IF I CAN I'D LIKE TO ASK
ONE FINAL QUESTION REGARDING
MENTAL HEALTH. ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND DE
STIGMATIZING THE- SPEAKING OF
MENTAL CARE IS IMPORTANT NOT
JUST TO OUR CHILDREN WHO ARE IN
DURING A PANDEMIC BUT IT'S AS
IMPORTANT TO THE DOCTORS WHO
ARE FACING THIS VIRUS HAD ON IN
OUR HOSPITALS ACROSS THIS
NATION. POST TRAINING DR.
KIDNEY POSTDOCTORAL TRAINING
LICENSEES ARE AN ESSENTIAL PART
OF THIS FIGHT AND WE SHOULD NOT
PUNISH THEM FOR SEEKING THE
CARE THEY NEED TO REMAIN FIT
FOR THE COMBATING AGAINST. COOK
AT NINETEEN. CURRENTLY THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
ALLOWS THE MEDICAL BOARD TO
ISSUE A PROBATIONARY PTL DUE TO
THE ONGOING PSYCHIATRIC
TREATMENT. I'M CURIOUS DR
LAWSON AND MR PACIFICA IF YOU
MIGHT GO INTO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OR ENFORCEMENT
OF THIS CODE SECTION AND
WHETHER YOU PERCEIVE THIS AS AN
OBSTACLE OR SOURCE OF STIGMA
FOR MANY. WHO COULD BENEFIT
FROM MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT. DR
ARAMBULA AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION IF I MAY CARRY
WEB STAFF COUNSEL. PLEASE
PROCEED. ADD THE BOARD PRESHEAF
THIS QUESTION VERY MUCH AND HAS
TAKEN STEPS TO CHANGE ITS
APPLICATION QUESTIONS SO THAT
IT'S ASKING ABOUT. MENTAL
HEALTH OR PHYSICAL CONDITIONS
THAT. WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE APPLICANT'S ABILITY TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE SAFELY. IT'S
NOT ASKING ABOUT PAST ISSUES IS
NOTASKING ABOUT CONDITIONS
THAT ARE WELL CONTROLLED. IT'S
ASKING ABOUT IF THERE IS A
CONDITION THAT COULD IMPACT THE
SAFE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE AT
THIS TIME. AND BOB WAS A WORK
IN IN PROGRESS BUT THE BOARD
RECOGNIZED ABOUT IT DOES WANT
TO SUPPORT PHYSICIANS AND IT
AND- THAT DOES IN POST GRADUATE
TRAINING TO. GET THE CARE
NEEDED SO THAT THEY CAN BE
HEALTHY. STANDS SO THE BOARD
AUTHORIZED BY A CHANGE IN HOW
THOSE QUESTIONS ARE WORDED. AND
IT FEEL THAT THIS IS NOT A
BARRIER- IT IS A NECESSARY
QUESTION TO UNDERSTAND IF AN
APPLICANT HAS A CURRENT
CONDITION THAT IMPACTS THE SAFE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE BUT THE
BOARD IS NOT DIGGING IN TO
INDIVIDUALS HOUSE TREATMENT OR
ISSUES THAT ARE WELL CONTROLLED.
FIND ME THEN IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN P. TALES AND
HOW WE TREAT OTHER MEDICAL
DOCTORS DO THEY GET ASKED THE
SAME QUESTION REGARDING THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH. I DON'T AT THE
TIME OF APPLICATION THOSE
QUESTIONS ARE THERE THE SAME.
THERE'S NOT. FOLLOW UP QUESTION
AT A LATER TIME. BUT IF AN
ISSUE COMES TO THE BOARD'S
ATTENTION ABOUT THE MENTAL OR
PHYSICAL CONDITION THAT IMPACTS
SAFE PRACTICE THEN THE BOARD
WILL ASK THAT PERSON TO
VOLUNTARILY UNDERGOING
EVALUATION. AND IF THEY WON'T
AND THERE'S ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
JUSTIFY IT THE BOARD WILL SEEK
TO COMPEL AN EVALUATION AND
THIS IS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
I'M HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP OFFLINE
I JUST WANT TO ENSURE WE ARE
DOING WHAT WE CAN TO DE
STIGMATIZE WHAT ABSOLUTION
AWFULLY TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE
FOR MANY PROVIDERS ON THE FRONT
LINES. AND TO THOSE WHO ARE
WILLING TO REACH OUT AND SEEKHELP WE SHOULD BE FIGURING OUT
HOW TO SUPPORT THEM SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO SHOW UP
AND FIGHT ON OUR BEHALF. THANK
YOU DEFINITELY AGREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR UNDER THE
DOCTOR PAN. THANK YOU VERY AND-
THREE SHEETS OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE BOARD- SO
FIRST OF ALL JUST SORT OF
FOLLOWING ALONG WITH- DOCTORING
BILL AS- QUESTIONS- I KNOW IN
ISSUE NUMBER SIX WE TALKED
ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ARE COVERED NINETEEN PROVIDERS
IN ISSUE NUMBER FIVE POSITION
HEALTH AND WELLNESS PROGRAMS. I
GUESS I SHOULD- FIRST OF ALL
MAKE NOTE THAT NOT ONLY AM I A
PHYSICIAN THERE FOR I GUESS MY
TOPIC OF INTEREST I'M A
LICENSEE OF THE MEDICAL BOARD-
BUT ALSO- WAS FORMERLY A
RESIDENCY PROGRAM DIRECTOR AND
ACTUALLY A MEMBER OF THE
ACCREDITATION COUNCIL GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION- PRIOR TO
BEING THE LEGISLATURE- I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT. ACTUALLY WHEN I
WAS UP. YOU KNOW A PART OF
RUNNING A RESIDENCY PROGRAM I
DID- YEAH I DID I WAS AWARE OF
A PHYSICIAN WHO- BOTH IN
TRAINING AND AFTER GRADUATION
OF COURSE AND PRACTICE YOU DID
HAVE SOME MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. BUT YET THE- WHEN
WE TRIED TO APPROACH THE
MEDICAL BOARD- IN TERMS OF. AND
AGAIN THIS IS A WHILE AGO SO I
DID I'M NOT SAYING THAT THIS
MAY BE THE CASE NOW- BUT THERE
REALLY WEREN'T PROGRAMS TO HELP
THIS POSITION BE ABLE TO- AND
CONTINUE TO. PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR CONTINUE PRACTICE I MEAN
THAT'S NOT WHAT SOLELY NOT THE
JOB IN AMERICA WERE TO DO THAT-
THE MEDICAL BOARD COURSE DOES
HAVE RESPONSIBILITIES IN TERMS
OF. CONSUMER PROTECTION SO FOUR
THIRTY TO SPEAK TO WHAT WE'RE
DOING- BECAUSE I SORT OF SEE
THIS ISSUE FIVE AND SIX
TOGETHER. TO HELP SUPPORT
POSITIONS WHO MAY BE SUFFERING
FROM MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES- BUT-
ONES THAT WOULD STILL ALLOW
THEM TO CONTINUE TO PRACTICE
AND- AGAIN I THINK THE
DRESSINGS THESEGMENT ISSUES
WELL. THAT THEY CAN DO THIS AND
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO BE
FORTHCOMING WITHOUT HAVING A
MARK ON HEIR ESSENTIALLY THEIR
LICENSING RECORD THAT AND OF
COURSE. LEADS TO- I DON'T
SCREEN IS NOT THE RIGHT WORD
BECAUSE- WE WHAT. WE DON'T KNOW
SAITO'S SCRUTINY BUT WE DON'T
HAVE STIGMA AND THEN HAVING
THEM BASICALLY BE LIMITED
ABILITY TO PRACTICE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE THIS MARKUPS. TRAILS THEM
EVERY TIME THEY APPLY FOR A-
MEDICAL STAFF- APPLICATION OR-
ANY OTHER THING BECAUSE WE KNOW
IT'S NOT JUST IN THE LICENSE
THAT YOU NEED TO PRACTICE YOUR
BOARD CERTIFICATION YOU HAVE.
MEDICAL STAFF PRIVILEGES- MANY
OTHER MECHANISMS IN PLACE THAT
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
THE PUBLIC. WHEN IT COMES TO
PHYSICIANS NEEDS SO CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THE MEDICAL BOARD'S
WORK AND- PROVIDING THAT KIND
OF SUPPORT. IN A NON
STIGMATIZING WAY ESPECIALLY NOW
THAT WE'RE BECAUSE CODED AND
OUT OF WILL NOT POST CODE FORTY
ONE MINUTES AGO THEN WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S MANY. EALTH
PROFESSIONALS INCLUDING
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE. WHO ARE.
YOU KNOW THAT BASICALLY TRYING
TO LIVE A TRAUMA. YEAH SIR SIR
CENTER PAM ALL RIGHT SURE YOUR
CONCERN. THAT THERE ARE MANY
ISSUES AND PROBLEMS THAT
PHYSICIANS HAVE. THAT CANNOT BE
DEALT WITH IN THE PUNITIVE WAY
BUT REQUIRE SUPPORT- AND TO
REQUIRES AN EMPHASIS ON.
GETTING THEM WELL. I CERTAINLY-
WHEN I RIDE ONE. THING THAT I
NOTICED IS THAT THERE WAS NO
POSITION HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PROGRAM. CURRENTLY IN PLACE- AS
YOU WOULD BE WELL NO THERE IS A
LONG SOCIAL HISTORY TO THAT.
BUT IT HAS BEEN A PRIORITY OF
THE BOARD TO GET ONE. BACK UP
AND RUNNING. WE CAN GIVE YOU
DETAILS OF EVERYTHING THAT WE
ARE DOING THEIR THE LEGISLATION
HAS BEEN PASSED. WE'VE DONE
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PUT THE
REGULATIONS IN PLACE- AND I CAN
ASK OUR STAFF COUNSEL. MS WEBB
TO GIVE YOU SOME DETAILS ON
WHERE WE ARE IN THAT PROJECT
AND WHAT WE HOPE TO DO WITH IT.
CREDIT MAYBE FOCUS I'D
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE- WITH THAT
INFORMATION AND PERHAPS- SHE
CAN FOCUS REMARKS ARE
SPECIFICALLY ON HOW TO ENSURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A STIGMA
FOLLOWING THIS AFTER. A
PHYSICIAN WHOSE FORTHCOMING. AS
WELL. YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THAT CENTER PAM FOR THIS
QUESTION AND- IT THE AS YOU MAY
KNOW THE BOARD STAFF DID DRAFT.
THOSE REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT
THE POSITION HEALTH AND
WELLNESS PROGRAM AND THEN THERE
WAS A MOVEMENT TO CHANGE THE
UNIFORM STANDARDS FOR SUBSTANCE
ABUSING MY CINCY IS WHICH THE
BOARD'S. PHYSICIAN HEALTH AND
WELLNESS PROGRAM MUST FOLLOW
AND SO. THE BOARD STAFF
REDRAFTED BE OPPOSE REGULATIONS
SO THAT EVERY TIME THERE WAS A
CHANGE SHOULD THE UNIFORM
STANDARDS THEY WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE CHANGED
AND CHANGED TO THE REGULATIONS
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM AND I
AM VERY HAPPY TO SAY THAT DCAS
REGULATIONS UNIT HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AS E'RE
WORKING THROUGH THAT ECONOMIC
INTERESTS TO SCHOOL TIME
INFORMATION THAT HAS TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE RULEMAKING
PACKAGE. AND SO DOT WILL BE
MAKING PROGRESS WITH THE REVIEW
PROCESS THAT IS REQUIRED TO
THREE D. CA AND BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY SO GREAT PROGRESS HAS
BEEN MADE THERE- AS FAR AS THE-
STIGMA- DE PHYSICIAN HEALTH AND
WELLNESS PROGRAM WILL ALLOW
PHYSICIANS TO SELF REPORT AND
TO YOU BECOME A PARTICIPANT IN
THAT PROGRAM WITHOUT A REPORT
BEING MADE TO THE BOARD SO LONG
AS THEY ARE FULLY COMPLIANT
WITH ALL OF THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE PROGRAM SHE AND THAT THE
UNIFORM STANDARDS ARE QUITE
STRICT. AND SO IF- THEY'RE NOT
FULLY COMPLIANT THEN THEY WILL
BE REPORTED TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD AND THAT WILL PUT THAT
POSITION IN THE ENFORCEMENT
PART BLACK- THIS A REQUIREMENT
OF THE UNIFORM STANDARDS. AND
SO IT WILL BE OVER A
REQUIREMENT OF THE PHYSICIAN
HEALTH AND WELLNESS PROGRAM- I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE CONCERNS
THAT. THAT WILL MAKE IT LESS
LIKELY FOR SOMEONE TO SELL
HARPER- HEY. THAT IS A
REQUIREMENT IN THE BOARD WILL
FOLLOW THAT- I KNOW THAT THIS
IS IMPORTANT TO YOU. CONSUMER
ADVOCATES WHO HAVE A HISTORY
WITH THE BOARDS AND NOW DEFUNCT
DIVERSION PROGRAM- WHICH ENDED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. THE
PHYSICIAN HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PROGRAM IS NOT A DIVERSION
PROGRAM. SO GEN IF A PHYSICIAN
SELF PREFERS AND IS NOT FULLY
COMPLIANT THEN. SENATE ACTION
MAYBE THAT'LL COME. THE BRITISH
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER I THINK
IT'S UNFORTUNATE- WELL
CERTAINLY THAT THE PREVIOUS
DIVERSION PROGRAM THAT HAVE
SOME ISSUES- THAT THERE ARE
SOME WHO ARE OUT THERE WHO-
UNFORTUNATELY PLAY ON THE FEARS
OF THE PUBLIC- TO- TO
ESSENTIALLY WE TALKED ABOUT THE
DECREASING ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE WELL WE HAVE PHYSICIANS-
AND JUMP PHYSICIANS ARE PEOPLE
TOO THEY'RE NOT PERFECT- AND-
AND SO YOU- AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND POSITION THE BOARDS
AND- BUT I THINK YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO BE REASONABLE- AND WE
WANT TO BE SURE WE ARE TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC BUT
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC IN.
REALITY NOT JUST SYMBOLICALLY
AND- THEREFORE DENYING
OPPOSITION TO COULD PROVIDE
SERVICES TO HE DIED VERY MUCH
NEEDED SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC
THAT- THAT WE'RE NOT YOU KNOW
WE'RE DEBATE NOT NIT PICKING
THEM TO DEATH- AND ALSO
CREATING HERE- AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WERE
WILLING TO COME FORWARD RIGHT-
SO THEY ACCEPT THE FACT THEY
HAVE A BIG ISSUE AND- AND THEN
BUT YET CREATING AT THE POLICY
YEAR OVER OVER THEM- THE DUTY
IS FOR PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY SELF.
TO SEEK HELP AND I THINK THAT'S
KIND OF PRODUCTIVE BUT I
APPRECIATE THE POSITION THE
BOARD IS IN IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND PERHAPS
WE CAN REVISIT THIS. ISSUE
LEGISLATIVELY IN THE FUTURE.
BEFORE YOU MOVE ON. PER MAY I
TO THE THIS IS HOWARD CRY.
BRIEFLY I DO HAVE MARK. SURE
BUT BUT BUT I AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE BOARD OR ACUTELY AWARE
OF THIS PROBLEM I. WAS
PERSONALLY ACQUAINTED WITH
THREE PHYSICIANS IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY WHO. COMMITTED
SUICIDE AND THESE WERE NOT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE CASES THESE
WERE JUST. EST INDIVIDUALS WHO
FEARED THE STIGMA OF COMING
FORWARD AND HAVING TO.
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR ROLE THEIR
DEPRESSION- AND IS SERVING ON
THE FEDERATION FOR STATE
MEDICAL BOARDS- IT'S EVIDENT.
THAT THIS IS A NATIONAL PROBLEM
AND RESIDENCY PROGRAMS ARE
ACTIVELY- WORKING ON THESE
ISSUES HOSPITALS HAVE POSITION.
AND WELLNESS PROGRAMS AND
COMMITTEES. AND I THINK IT'S A
GLARING DEFECTS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A WELL FUNCTIONING.
OPPOSITION HEALTH AND WELLNESS
PROGRAM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ON AND I KNOW THAT
THIS SENTIMENT AND ACTIONS OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD. OR TO TRY
TO- RECONSTRUCTION EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM. WITH COOPERATION OF
ALL STAKEHOLDERS. POST HASTE.
CHAU NO THAT OUR SYMPATHIES AND
OUR INTENTION. OR TO ALLOW
DOCTORS TO SELF DESIGNATE AND
TO RECEIVE THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED. WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING THE
LICENSURE SO LONG AS STATED BY
MISS WEB. WE HAVE ADEQUATE
ASSURANCES THAT THERE'S NO
PUBLIC JEOPARDY. THIS IS AN
ISSUE OF GREAT CONCERN SENATOR
PAT THANK YOU. APPRECIATE THAT
IN FACT WHEN PEOPLE SELF
DISCLOSE WE CAN PUT HIM UNDER
SUPERVISION WE CAN DO OTHER
THINGS PRIOR WHICH IF THEY
DIDN'T. THEN THERE WOULD NOT BE
THAT SUPERVISION BUT ALSO PUT
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BRING UP
TO HIGH RATES UNFORTUNATELY. OF
PHYSICIAN SUICIDE WHICH IS
HIGHER THAN THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
AND WHAT THAT DOES TO DENY CARE
TO COMMUNITIES AND HOW THAT
AFFECTS OUR PUBLIC HEALTH- THE
OTHER QUITE NEXT QUESTION
ACTUALLY INTERESTING ENOUGH WE
TALKED ABOUT THE- DETAILS-
BECAUSE TRAINING LICENSES-
INTERESTING ENOUGH I KNOW ISSUE
TEN WE TALK ABOUT LICENSING
TIME FRAMES- APPRECIATE. THE
WITH THE PRESENTATION OF THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE TO MAKE
THAT MORE EFFICIENT- I NOTED
THAT- IT'S REPORTED THAT. THAT
THAT- BASICALLY- WORD THE
AVERAGE TIME NOW FOR GETTING A
LICENSETWENTY NINE DAYS OUT
OF. MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WAS A TOOK OVER. SIX MONTHS.
FOR ME TO YET AND MY INITIAL
AND- THERE WAS NO ISSUE THAT
THE MAY ISSUE ACTUALLY I CAN
OUTSIDE WHICH I. PTL AND THOSE
A CONTINUE BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN THIS IS
DECADES AGO AND THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF MASSACHUSETTS WHICH OF
COURSE I HAD. NO NO PROBLEMS OF
MY LICENSE BUT BECAUSE OF THE
P. T. L. THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA WOULDN'T ACCEPT IT.
SO NOW IT'S FINE IT'S
INTERESTING WHEN HAVING
DISCUSSION ABOUT DETAILS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA- BUT I HOPE THAT-
THAT THERE'S SOME CONVERSATION
ON CALIFORNIA'S WORKING WITH
OTHER STATES I KNOW SOME OF
THIS HAVE TO DO WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT THERE
ARE I SHOULD POINT OUT THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN. WELL WE HAVE
SOME CHALLENGES WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF DETAIL THERE-
PUT THERE ARE SEVERAL REASONS
WHY IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO DO ONE-
BUT I HOPE THAT- BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT- THE
MEDICAL BOARD KEEPS- ARE
COMMITTEES UP TO DATE AND ALSO
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT WE CAN TRY
TO DO TO HELP. I REALIZE THAT
MANY OF THE ISSUES ARE ACTUALLY
DECISIONS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SEES A DETOX STANCE
ABOUT THE X. WAIVER- THE MEDIC
CAL PROGRAM WE CAN CERTAINLY
AYE KNOWS REACHED OUT TO DCS
ABOUT THIS- THERE'S SOME CMS
ISSUES. BUT WE REALLY SHOULD
TRY TO WORK TOGETHER WITH OTHER
STATES AS YOU SAID TO DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS- AND RECOGNITION
DATA. RESTRAINING LICENSE IS
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED-
EQUIVALENT TO A FULL LICENSE.
OTHER THAN THE FACT THAT THE
LICENSEES UNDER- THE SUIT. OF
RESIDENTS. RESIDENCY PROGRAM
BUT SHOULD OTHERWISE BE
TREATED. BY WHETHER IT'S PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR VITAL RECORDS OR BY.
YOU KNOW- GOVERNMENT- HEALTH
PROGRAMS OR- OTHER AGENCIES AS
A FULL LICENSE AND- WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE PUSHING THAT. AS
A- AS A POLICY- AS- SENATOR IF
I CAN JUST INTERJECT THERE VERY
BRIEFLY BRIEFLY. I CAN ASSURE
YOU THE MEDICAL BOARD IS
WORKING VERY CLOSELY. WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. TO DO EXACTLY
THAT OKAY WE ARE WORKING WITH
STAFF TO MEET SHAREHOLDERS. WE
ARE DEDICATED TO RESOLVING THE
PROBLEM. OKAY THANK YOU BUT I
THINK IT'S AWFULLY WE CAN
CLEARLY WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
THE GENERAL POSITION SHOULD BE
IS THAT PTL OPPOSE TRAINING
LICENSE SHOULD BE CONSIDERED BY
ALL OTHER AGENCIES. AS
EQUIVALENT TO A FULL LICENSE-
ISSUE NUMBER NINE. SON
CONDITION AND SEES- I KNOW WE
TOUCHED ON THIS BEFORE AND THIS
IS A REPEATED ISSUE FOR
MULTIPLE BOARDS. BUT ONCE AGAIN
I HAVE TO REMIND PEOPLE- ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE HERE
AND THEY REALIZE IT'S NOT JUST
FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD BUT- IS
WHAT DOJ'S CHARGING THE VARIOUS
BOARDS. AND I WOULD JUST. AGAIN
REMIND PEOPLE IF YOU LOOK AT
THE HOURLY ATE THAT THEY'RE
BEING CHARGED. ESSENTIALLY FOR
AN ATTORNEY IT'S EQUIVALENT OF.
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY SIX OVER
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND A YEAR- IF THAT WAS A
FULL TIME ATTORNEY. AS A
PARALEGAL WOULD BE A FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. AND FERN
ANALYSTS TO BE FOUR HUNDRED
FIVE THOUSAND YEAR NOW THE
REALITY AGAIN IS THAT A SENIOR
LET'S. LEGAL ANALYSTS- ACTUALLY
GETS PAID BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AT THE TOP VERY TOP
OF THEIR SALARY RANGES ONLY
810-002-0050 TWO SO I'M NOT
SURE WHY THE- OF. BOARD WOULD
BE CHARGE 400-500-0600 DOLLARS
A YEAR. FOR SOMEONE TO GET
PAID. EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND. AND
EVEN A SUPERVISING DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHICH IS THE
HIGHEST RANKING- LAWYER- THAT'S
A SHORT OF- GETS PAID AT THE
TOP END OF THEIR PAY. COURT TO
CAL EIGHT CHAR HUNDRED SEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR DOLLARS A YEAR AT THE TOP
AND THAT'S NOT THE AVERAGE TOP
AND- YET WE'RE THE BOARDS ARE
BEING CHARGED FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER YEAR. FOR
AN ATTORNEY. AND I'M SURE WE'RE
NOT GETTING A SUPERVISING
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL EVERY
TIME DOING TO INVESTIGATIONS I
REALLY THINK WE DO NEED TO LOOK
VERY CAREFULLY AT. THAT THIS
COST RIGHT FOR WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR BOARDS INCLUDING MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. AND THEN
FINALLY- I DO WANT TO BRING UP-
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN I KNOW
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT- SOME
MEMBER BLOOM AND I. WORKED ON-
AND I HOPE THAT TO IN OUR-
LEGISLATION TO- TO RE AUTHORIZE
THE BOARD THAT WE ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE I KNOW THERE WAS SAYS
THAT THERE'S A VERY POSITIVE
QUESTIONS. UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
THEY TAP INTO THE VERY AND THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION WE WERE
ABLE TO PUT THEM INTO THIS INTO
A SUMMER BLOOMS- FINALISATION
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY THREE BUT
INCLUDE A REQUIREMENT. FOR
ACCREDITATION AND- BY AS AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION AS A
REQUIREMENT FOR AN INSTITUTION
TO. BE ABLE TO GET A- SPECIALTY
FACULTY PERMIT- SO I KNOW IT'S
ME NOTE AND- STAFF REPORT BUT
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
AGREED TO- AND I HOPE WE CAN.
IMPLEMENT IT IN. AS PART OF
THE- LEGISLATION RE IN RENEWING
THE BOARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR FAN CLUB CENTER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- I'D LIKE TO GIVE IT A
LITTLE BIT AWAY- AND ASKED
ABOUT LICENSED MIDWIFE- WE
PASSED LEGISLATION LAST YEAR-
IN THE BOARD WAS GONNA- DID
CREATE THE- THE PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY THAT THAT STALLED
WHAT'S THE WHAT WHAT IS THE-
THE STATUS OF THE- LICENSED
MIDWIFE INDEPENDENT PRACTICE
AUTHORITY AND- DO WE NEED TO
MAKE ANY CHANGES OR WHAT DO YOU
NEED TO BE ABLE TO. MAKE SURE
THAT THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATION IS- IS ACHIEVED. HI
THIS IS SERRA KERRY WEBER AGAIN
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION- THE MEDICAL BOARD
LICENSES AND REGULATES LICENSED
MIDWIVES AND THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. WHY SINCE
IS A REGULATORS CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES AND- CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES THAT WERE RECENTLY
GRANTED THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE. LICENSE
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY WITHOUT
PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND THAT IS
THE REASON WHY THE BOARD
SUPPORTS THEM ACTUALLY HAVING
THEIR OWN BOARD AND TO BE OUT
FROM UNDER THE MEDICAL BOARD
SINCE PHYSICIAN SUPERVISION HAS
NOT BEEN REQUIRED FOR SOME TIME.
THAT IS THAT IS THAT SOMETHING
BECAUSE THEY'RE A LICENSE UNDER
TWO DIFFERENT BOARDS THAT WE
NEED MORE LEGISLATION TO BE
ABLE TO- FURTHER MAKE THAT
CLEAR. THIS APP IS A PART OF
ADDING TO THE CONFUSION. ON IT.
I THINK THERE IS CONFUSION
BECAUSE- CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES ARE ACTUALLY
REGISTERED NURSES TO DAN DEAD
ADDITIONAL TRAINING TO BECOME
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES
LICENSED MIDWIVES HAVE THEIR
OWN PATHWAY THAT IS DIFFERENT
FROM THE MEDICAL MODEL. AND
THEY- AND MOSTLY D. PROVIDE
SERVICES IN THEIR CLIENTS HOMES
WHERE A CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES- VERY FREQUENTLY
PROVIDE. THEIR SERVICES IN
HOSPITAL SETTINGS FOR OUR BIRTH
CENTERS- SO THAT THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT. MODELED. HOW TO
DIFFERENT- S. IS ON THAT
PREGNANCY LAY DAY. AND THEIR
REGULAR BY TWO DIFFERENT BUT IT
DOES CREATE CONFUSION BECAUSE
THEY'RE BOTH MIDWIVES. OKAY
THANK YOU AND THEN ADJUSTED TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC IN THERE ARE A LOT OF
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT WERE WORK
ISSUED- IF SINCE MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ARE THERE ARE THERE
ANYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
CONTINUED OR IS THERE ANY
WAIVERS THAT WARRANT ANY
STATUTORY CHANGES- ANY ISSUES
RESULTING FROM THE PANDEMIC
THAT YOU'VE HAD TO DEAL WITH.
HI IF I MAY THIS IS FRAN
O'CONNOR- ADDRESS THAT QUESTION.
PLEASE YES- THERE YES AS YOU
SAID THERE WAS A NUMBER OF
WAIVERS TO LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE ISSUED
BY THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER-
A COUPLE OF THOSE ADDRESSTO BE
EXPIRATION BY WHICH A-
RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA MUST
OBTAIN A POSTGRADUATE TRAINING
LICENSE- THEY HAVE CURRENTLY
UNDER THE CURRENT LEVER UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH- CERTAIN
RESIDENTS THAT MEET THE
CRITERIA HAVE TILL JUNE
THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR TO
OBTAIN A PTL- WE ARE. STILL
LOOKING AT- WHETHER OR NOT
THOSE NEED TO BE EXTENDED OR
NOT WE USUALLY- YOU KNOW KEEP
AN EYE ON WHEN WE GET CLOSE TO
THAT DATE- WHAT THE IMPACT
WOULD BE IF THE WAIVER WAS NOT
EXTENDED BEFORE MAKING THAT
DECISION- BUT THOSE ARE TWO WE
ARE KEEPING OUR EYE ON AND
THERE'S ALSO A CONTINUING
MEDICAL EDUCATION WAIVER FOR
PHYSICIANS- UNLESS AS MIDWIVES
CURRENTLY- THEY HAVE A SIX
MONTH EXTENSION TO. COMPLETE
THEIR CONTINUING MEDICAL
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS- WHICH
BASICALLY GIVES UNTIL ABOUT
AUGUST- SO THAT'S ANOTHER-
WEAVER WORK WE'RE LOOKING AT-
AND- THERE'S OTHER WAIVERS THAT
HAVE BEEN RECENTLY- ISSUED-
THAT IMPACT- THE- DETAILS
ABILITY TO- ADMINISTER THE
COVETED NINETEEN VACCINE- AS
WELL AS- THINK.
THERE MIGHT BE
SOME OTHER THAT. THANK YOU US
CENTER EGGMAN IF I COULD JUST
FOLLOW UP ON. THE SENATORS
LICENSED MIDWIFE QUESTION. A
BIT IT WAS IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT AB THIRTEEN
AWAIT IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
REMOVE THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT FOR A LICENSED
MIDWIFE TO PRACTICE UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF AN OF AN MD
PHYSICIAN AND INSTEAD SPECIFIED
THAT A MIDWIFE MAY ASSIST IN
NORMAL PREGNANCY. AND BIRTH THE
BOOK DEFINED BY REGULATIONS AND
OUR ANALYSIS RECORD ON PAPER
ANYWAY I'M SURE THAT YOU WILL
HAVE READ. INDICATES THAT THE
BOARD HELD SEVERAL INTERESTED
PARTY MEETINGS ON THE
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT AB
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT INCLUDING
WORKING WITH A VARIETY OF
ASSOCIATIONS AND ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THE BACKGROUND PAPER NOTES
A STICKING POINT IN THE
DISCUSSION ON REGULATIONS WAS A
LACK OF AGREEMENT ON WHETHER
PRIOR. SYRIAN SECTION C.
SECTION SHOULD BE ON THE LIST
OF PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE A PHYSICIAN
AND SURGEON EXAMINATION. PRIOR
TO THE LICENSED MIDWIFE
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE CARE
PURSUANT TO. BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE SECTION TWENTY
FIVE OH SEVEN. HAS THIS RATE
YOU KNOW YOU MENTIONED THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CERTIFIED
AND LICENSED MIDWIVES IN THIS
THAT THE OTHER HAS THAT
REGULATORY IMPEDIMENT BEEN
RESOLVED AND ARE LICENSED
MIDWIVES UNDER THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT NOW FREE TO.
INDEPENDENTLY PRACTICE PURSUANT
TO THE STATUTE. CENTER PROCESS
I MAY ANSWER THIS. I HAD. THAT
REGULATORY REGULATORY HAS NOT
BEEN THE BUT MIDWIVES ARE
PRACTICE IN THE- THERE'S. USING
MIDWIFERY STANDARD OF CARE AND
THEIR JUDGMENT. AND THERE HAS
BEEN SEVERAL AT TEN TO WORK THE
LEAD TO GET SOME CLARIFYING-LANGUAGE BECAUSE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES WORDY- INCLUDED IN
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
TWENTY FIVE OH SEVEN- FOR
EXAMPLE- IT USES THE WORD.
WHITE LEE. AND THERE ARE SO ANY
PREVIOUS MATERNAL DISEASE OR
CONDITION OR LIKELY TO AFFECT A
PREGNANCY WELL THAT IS- YOU.
MORE LIKELY THAN NOT. AND THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF CONDITIONS
WHERE IT'S NOT LIKELY TO AFFECT
THE PREGNANCY BUT THERE IS THIS
MEDICAL RISK FOR THE DELIVERY
TO OCCUR AT HOME- SO. THE BOARD
DID SEEK. TODAY TO HAVE THAT
CHANGED AS WELL AS THE REPORT.
FOR WINTER CONSULTATION WITH A
PHYSICIAN TO HAVE THE PHYSICIAN
DETERMINED THAT THE CLIENT'S
CONDITION OUR CONCERN HAS BEEN
RESOLVED SUCH THAT THE RISK
FACTORS PRESENTED BY WOMEN'S
DISEASE OR CONDITION ARE NOT
LIKELY TO SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECT
THE COURSE OF PREGNANCY OR
CHILDBIRTH WELL THAT'S THIS
PUTS PHYSICIANS IN A TERRIBLE
POSITION AND- WE HAVE BEEN TOLD
THAT MY ABILITY INSURANCE DOES
NOT SUPPORT POSITIONS. ENGAGING
IN THIS KIND OF CONSULTATION
AND MAKING THAT DETERMINATION.
THAT WILL- THE CLIENT TO RETURN
TO THE PRIME CARE OF THEIR
MIDWIVES. AND SO ANOTHER WHERE
BOARD LEGISLATOR SUPPORT TO- IT
BASICALLY HAVE A DO THIS. AND
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION SO THAT
THE CLIENT MAKE IN AND DECISION
ON WHETHER- IF IT HOME BIRTH IS
APPROPRIATE IN THE MIDWIFE
NEEDS TO MAKE THE DECISION
WHETHER IT'S WITHIN THE
STANDARD OF CARE SHE CONTINUED
TO BE THE PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER
FOR THEIR CLIENTS- SO FAR THAT.
HAS NOT HAPPENED- IN THIS IS A
THE- RELATIONSHIP BE AN- AND SO.
THE BOARD AGAIN SUPPORT IS A
MIDWIVES. HAVING THEIR OWN.
FOR- AND IF THAT IS NOT
POSSIBLE THEN WE DO NEED TO
ADDRESS THE DIFFICULT LANGUAGE
IN THIS. THE CARD SECTION WELL
THE BOARD IS A SEPARATE ISSUE
HAVING TO DO WITH- STRUCTURAL
ISSUES AND WHETHER OF A
SEPARATE BOARD CAN. CAN
FUNCTION OR WHETHER IT'S GOING
TO START OUT IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT SITUATION DEPENDING ON
THE NUMBER OF LICENSEES IN THE
FEES THEY CAN FURTHER A WHOLE
VARIETY OF ISSUES. INCLUDING
I'M SURE PRACTICE ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A SEPARATE
BOARD BUT I THINK WHAT THE
SENATOR WAS ATTEMPTING TO GET
IT IS WHAT SORT OF FIX DO YOU
NEED. IF THERE IS ANY
IMPEDIMENT TO INDEPENDENT
PRACTICE OF THESE LICENSED
MIDWIVES AND YOU. INDICATED
THAT THEY'RE PRACTICING
INDEPENDENTLY BUT HOW DO THEY
PRACTICE. INDEPENDENTLY IF THE
STATUTE ALLOWS THEM TO ASSIST
IN A NORMAL PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH AND WE AND NOBODY IS
DEFINED WHAT THAT IS. THAT'S A
QUESTION BUT LET ME RAINY LET
ME ASK ANOTHER ONE I'M NOT A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER I'M
CERTAINLY NOT A PHYSICIAN. I
USED TO BE A LAWYER. NOT
ANYMORE. I GUESS. THAT I'VE-
BEEN A MEMBER OF VARIOUS
HOSPITAL BOARDS IN THE WAY BACK
AND I REMEMBER. I SEEM TO
REMEMBER THAT THERE WAS THIS
DEBATE OVER C. SECTIONS AND
WHETHER. AFTER A C. SECTION YOU
SHOULD HAVE A NORMAL DELIVERY
OR NOT HAVE A NORMAL DELIVERY
OR BE. HAVE ANOTHER C. SECTION
AND SO THIS WHOLE LACK OF
AGREEMENT ON CURRENCY SECTION.
SEEMS TO BE SORT OF AN
IMPEDIMENT WHICH WAS THE
QUESTION ARE THERE ANY
IMPEDIMENTS AND HOW. I GUESS WE
NEED TO KNOW SPECIFICALLY WHAT
WE NEED TO DO IN A SUNSET BILL
IN ORDER TO ALLOW LICENSED
MIDWIVES TO PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY WITHIN THE
MEANING OF THE STATUTE. CAN YOU
HELP US. OKAY WELL. DO WE NEED
TO MAKE THE DECISION ON WHETHER
SOMEONE WHO HAS A PRIOR C.
SECTION MAY BE ATTENDED BY A
LICENSED MIDWIFE. I CAN TELL
YOU THAT LICENSE BID WIVES ARE
PERFORMING E. B. BACKS AT HOME-
THE ISSUE IS CLIENT SELECTION.
AND I THINK OVER ALL LICENSED
MIDWIVES TAKE GREAT CARE IN-
THEY'RE SELECTING AS CLIENTS
AND TO THEIR RETAIN US CLIENTS
THAT THE CONDITION ARISES. AND
SO THAT'S HOW THE PRACTICE.
INDEPENDENTLY IS THAT- THEY
HAVE TO FOLLOW THE LEGISLATION
AND SO THEY CAN'T TAKE ON CASES
WHERE THERE'S- AND IT YOU MORE
THAN THAN. THEN WHY FEEDER-
DATE CAN'T BE BURIED. THEY HAVE
TO. YOU FOLLOW THE NEWS PERIOD
DELIVERIES EXPECT THAT GO OVER
OR OR BE TREAT- ANDS. YOUR DAY
HAVE TO FOLLOW THE STATE OF
CARE TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
MAKING GET THIS ABOUT CLIENTS.
AND CURRENTLY NOT REGULAR THAT
FURTHER THE FINAL- THE YOU KNOW
THE POOR HAS NOT. A POSITION ON
FOR SURE BE BACK NUMBER
LICENSED MIDWIVES IN THE HOME
INSIDE AND I'M TO COME WHAT
BOARD BECAUSE TODAY IN THAT
REGARD OKAY THAT IS UP TO THE
BY JUST TO. IN YOU FURTHER TO
NOT AND IN THE PORT OF COURSE
THIS AND- IT. WELL IN ON THAT
ONCE THERE'S LANGUAGE AVAILABLE
WITH YOU I MAY HAVE SOME OTHER
FOR LET ME TO FOR TO MY CAN
MEMBERS DR WEBER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- FOR THE COMP. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK- I
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
AROUND A MIDWIFE- AS PRACTICING
A- I ENTER THE TIME. THAT WE
ARE TO TODAY- YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ARE. YOU
KNOW THE BACKS VAGINAL BIRTH
THAT SEASON IT'S BEEN AT DEBATE
FOR A LONG TIME. AS TO THE
SAFETY WERE NOT A SAFE AND
WHERE YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO
IT- AND HOW MANY TIMES IF
YOU'VE HAD MULTIPLE C.
SECTIONS- HOW OFTEN WILL THAT
YOU HAVE A FEEDBACK FOR TEN
THIRTY BACK AFTER THAT- AND
WHETHER OR NOT IT IS SAFE TO
HAVE SOMEONE. DELIVER VAGINALLY
AFTER THEY'VE HAD A C. SECTION
AT HOME ON WHERE THEY'RE NOT
BEING ABLE TO BE MONITORED SO.
THESE ARE DEFINITELY ONGOING-
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING IN THE IN THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING TO UPDATE SOME OF OUR
BUSINESS CODE IN PROFESSIONS
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WITHIN THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION WE
UNDERSTAND ESPECIALLY IN THE
REALM OF OBGYN THERE IS NO
QUOTE NORMAL. PREGNANCY BECAUSE
THINGS CAN CHANGE- AND I AN
INSTANT SOMEONE CAN COME IN
WITH NO MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS
OF HAD A PREFABRICATED NORMAL.
THIRTY NINE WEEKS AND THEN COME
ON TO LABOR AND DELIVERY AND
ABRUPT. SO WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THINGS CAN HAPPEN- IN A VERY
VERY QUICK. TIME FRAME FOR THE.
MOST ON- I. OF PATIENT THAT HAD
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO AND TO GIVE
OUR PATIENTS OPTION. AND THAT
THERE IS. IN PRACTICE- AN OBGYN
AND I MIDDLE SIR- MASSANA I
SAID I LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSS
THESE IS SO THAT WE CAN FOR.
OUR PATIENTS WITH OPTIONS
BETTER SAFE THAN THAT WE END UP
HAVING SAFE MOTHERS AND SAFE
BABIES THAT'S WHAT I ALWAYS
TELL MY PATIENTS THAT AT THE
END OF THE DAY WHAT WE WANT IS
FOR A SAFE MOMMY AND SAFE BABY
AND FOR EVERYBODY TO BE ABLE TO
GO HOME AT THE SAME TIME- I DID
HAVE ONE QUESTION ABOUT THE
TASK FORCE THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
AND I UNDERSTAND. THE DESIRE
TO- CREATE A SEPARATE BOARD AND
THAT MAY. HAPPEN AND THAT YOU
KNOW MAYBE A DIFFERENT
DISCUSSION. BUT WITH THE TASK
FORCE THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
THERE WAS A- I MENTIONED THAT
THERE WAS NO. LIKE MIDWIFE ON
THERE WAS THERE EVER ANY
THOUGHT TO CHANGE IT OVER TO
LIKE MAYBE A STANDING COMMITTEE
OR SOMETHING WHERE YOU DO. HAVE
THE INPUT. OF SOMEONE FROM THE
MIDWIFERY COMMUNITY. TO HELP.
FLESH OUT SOME OF THESE I AM.
VERY INTRICATE SIDE. THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW. SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T PRACTICE OF STATICS MAY
NOT UNDERSTAND. RIGHT AND THIS
IS KERRY WEBER AGAIN AND- THE
TOPS FOR. THAT YOU'RE TALKING
OF. AB DE MADE UP OF. TWO BOARD
FROM THE MEDICAL BOARD CHIEF
BOARD MEMBER. BUT WHEN THE-
FORCE MET- DOES MEETING
INCLUDED AND OF MIDWIVES THAT
ARE IN THE CAN- REPRESENTATIVES
A COG AND REPRESENTATIVES FROM
CMA TO TRY TO CRAFT LANGUAGE
THAT- COULD AVOID OP. AS IT
MOVES THROUGH THE VILLAGE. AND-
MANY MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT
FOLLOWING THAT MEETING. SUCH
LANGUAGE WAS CREATED HOWEVER-
THERE WERE CERTAIN FACTIONS
THAT WORKED TO- OPPOSE IT AND
SO THE FIX WAS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE BOARD'S LAST SUNSET HILL-
IT WAS DISAPPOINTING- BUT WERE
ALWAYS HELPFUL THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE THIS AREA BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE GAVE MIDWIVES THE
ABILITY TO PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY AND- YEAH WE NEED
TO HAVE. THE TOOLS IN PLACE
SAID BIDS CAN BE DONE
EFFECTIVELY AND SAFELY AND
RECOGNIZE THEM AS- THE
INDEPENDENT PRACTITIONERS THAT
THEY ARE- BUT- AND TO IMPROVE
THEIR ABILITY TO CONSULT- WITH
PHYSICIANS IN A COLLABORATIVE
WAY- I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE IS SAID MIDWIFERY
ADVISORY COUNCIL THAT MEETS
THREE TIMES A YEAR AND-
INTERACTS WITH THE BOARD DURING
BOARD MEETINGS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BOARD
FOR LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
CHANGES BUT THE STRUCTURE- IT
HAS ITS DIFFICULTIES FOR THE
REASONS THAT I'VE- SAID BEFORE.
MAKING WELL THANK YOU LETTER
SAID I LOW FORWARD PROTECT IN
DISCUSSIONS- AND HOW WE CAN
UPDATE OUR OWN BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE- SO THAT WE
CAN ALLOW YOU KNOW LICENSED
MIDWIVES TO PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY SAFELY- AS THE
LEGISLATIVE PREVIOUSLY- ALLOW
FOR IT THIS TOOK OTHER QUICK
THINGS- YOU KNOW I JUST WANNA.
ECHO WITH MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
TALKED ABOUT AS FAR AS REMOVING
YOU KNOW- THE STIGMA AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH- IT'S NOT- JUST
SOMETHING THAT WE SEE WITH
COVERT- IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR A
VERY LONG TIME WE HAVE-
PHYSICIAN BURNOUT. AND IF WE DO
NOT HAVE THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE
TO A PRO ACTIVELY SEEK CARE
WITHOUT BEING FEARED WITH SOME
KIND OF RETRIBUTION OR SOME
STIGMA THEN WE WILL DECREASE
THE NUMBER OF PHYSICIANS THAT
WE HAVE BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE. OR-
BORN FRENCH HORN FOR MY STATE
BEFORE THERE'S A VERY HIGH RATE
OF. AMONG PHYSICIANS AND SO
THAT ULTIMATELY IS TO. DECREASE
ACCESS FOR USUALLY OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. AND THE
OTHER THING I'M JUST WONDERING
IS WHEN YOU ALL COME BACK IF
YOU CAN GIVE ME A SCOPE OF THE
ISSUE OF THE- MOONLIGHTING- FOR
OUR OUR TRAINEES YOU KNOW AS A
RESIDENT- I STARTED RIGHT
AROUND THE TIME OF THE SWITCH
OF THE EIGHTY HOUR. WORK WEEK
REQUIREMENT AND SO WE WERE NO
LONGER ABLE TO DO MORE LIGHTING
AND I KNOW OUR RESIDENTS THAT
I'VE MOST RECENTLY WORKED WITH.
ARE UNABLE TO DO THAT BECAUSE
I'M IT WOULD GO OVER WORK. ON
OUR REQUIREMENTS. ON THE EIGHTY
HOUR WORK WEEK RULE. SO I'M
JUST WONDERING IF WHEN YOU COME
BACK IF YOU CAN KIND OF GIVE ME-
I HAD. SOME KIND OF SCOPE OF
THE ISSUE OF HOW MANY OF OUR
RESIDENTS ARE STILL ABLE AND
DESIRING TO DO MOONLIGHTING
SERVICES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE WEBER THOSE AND- A RUMOR. I
JUST FROM PURSE. ON THIS ISSUE
BEFORE I. LOOKING FOR MIKE'S
BEFORE I ASK YOU TO COMPLETE A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS. I HAVE
NOT REVIEWED THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE OF AB THIRTEEN AWAIT
AND I CERTAINLY WILL DIFFER ON
MY HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
COLLEAGUES- AND THOSE RELATED
TO THEM FOR. ADVICE AND
ASSISTANCE ON THIS BUT IF THE
STATUTE ITSELF CONTEMPLATED THE
ISSUANCE OF REGULATIONS. ON
THIS MATTER IN ORDER TO INFORM
LICENSE MIDWIVES WHEN THEY
PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY AND AT
LEAST IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN WHEN THE STATUTE WAS
ENACTED AND WE HAVEN'T ISSUED
REGULATIONS. ON THIS. REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. OF GUIDANCE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO IT
AND EITHER THE MEDICAL BOARD'S
GOING TO HAVE TO DO IT OR WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
IN THIS SUNSET REVIEW REVIEW
BILL OR OTHERWISE TO FURTHER
DEFINE THIS ISSUE SO THAT
LICENSED MIDWIVES AND
PHYSICIANS WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS KNOW WHAT THE SCOPE
OF PRACTICE IS. AND CAN BE
GUIDED BY IT. SO CENTER TOTALLY
SEE YOUR MAKE UP PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO ADD. TO THE COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS AT THE- MY
COLLEAGUES AT ASTOR LOOTED
EARLIER THIS MORNING AND IT
REALLY WANT TO ECHO- AT IT
MIGHT GET COLLEAGUES FROM AT
THE ASSEMBLY THAT DOCTOR WEBER
AND- SPEAKING TO. M. MIDWIFERY
HOW ABOUT HOW IT'S ABOUT SAFE
MOTHERS AND SAFE IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE SAFE BABIES I
REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS AND
SOME QUESTIONS IN IN THIS AREA-
THE FIRST- I DID LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND AND AN INFORMATION
GATHERING. AND I HAVE A NUMBER
OF FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
LICENSED MIDWIVES THAT- WERE AT
LEAST EXPECTED TO REPORT BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN- THERE
IS NO REPORT OF FOUR TWENTY
TWENTY BUT- YOU KNOW FIRST I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
THIS NUMBER IS MORE OR LESS
ACCURATE- I ALSO WANT TO. AB IT
YOU KNOW KIND OF LOOK AT WHAT
IT WHAT WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE
PER COUNTY- I KNOW THAT IN MY A
LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW DIGGING
THROUGH INFORMATION- FOR
EXAMPLE IN MARIN COUNTY THERE'S-
TWENTY. THAT NUMBER OF LIVE
BIRTHS AND IT SEEMS THAT THEY
HAD PRETTY GOOD YOU KNOW PRETTY
GOOD OUTCOMES AT LEAST TWO THE
REPORT THAT WAS PUBLISHED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN- BUT I WAS
WONDERING IF WE HAVE MORE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF. YOU KNOW OF
THAT INTO THAT REPORT- AND ALSO
WHAT I ALSO FOUND A LITTLE BIT-
ALARMING I WOULD SAY IS. I'D BE
INFORMATION ON- THE TRANSFER OF
CARE. OF ELDERLY CHART AND OR A
CLIENT- YOU KNOW SHORTLY BE- AT
VBAC AB BACK AND I APOLOGIZE
I'M NOT YOU KNOW THE V. G. Y.
AND R. DR JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
BUT- OUT YET THERE'S ABOUT
TWENTY ONE CLIENTS THAT HAD
DEVELOPED. HYPERTENSION DURING
THE PREGNANCY AND HAD TO BE
THAT THERE THERE ARE CARE HAD
TO BE TRANSFERRED. AND THERE
WAS A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE CLIENTS AND F.
SHORTLY BEFORE- YOU KNOW
DELIVERY. I THERE WAS ALL. INTO
TRANSFER CARE AT IN ISSUES LIKE
YOU PROLONGED RUPTURE OF
MEMBRANES AND- AND THAT HAD YOU
KNOW WHAT THE UMBER IS MUCH
HIGHER THERE WHEN IT COMES TO
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THAT-
THAT- YOU KNOW THE RECORD CAME
UP. SO I THINK THAT THIS THIS.
I HAVE SOME REAL CONCERNS ABOUT
ITS OWN ESTABLISHING ITS OWN-
BOARD GIVEN FACT. THERE COULD
BE COMPLICATIONS RIGHT- IT
COULD BE YOUR PRIOR TO OR
DURING. I DON'T REALLY KNOW TOO
MUCH BUT FROM MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THAT- THERE'S REAL
CONCERN ABOUT THE- AT THE
PATIENT AND THE CARE- AND THERE
SEEMS TO BE KIND OF TO KIND OF
TWO STANDARDS. NOT TO. APPS NOT
TO STANDARDS OF CARE BUT
THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT- A
PRACTICE ACTS THAT- THAT THAT
HAVE TO KIND OF. YOU KNOW
NOBODY OBGYN- ABIDES BY ONE-
PRACTICE ACTING IN THE
MIDWIFERY AT. ABIDES BY
DIFFERENT ONE SO- SO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COMMENT OR OR
PROVIDE AN ANSWER ON- MY
STATEMENT PLEASE. I'M HAPPY TO
COMMENT ON THAT CENTER HER
CHINA THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE QUESTION- YOU KNOW THE
TRANSFER OF CARE. THAT TELLS US
THAT MIDWIVES ARE ACTING
APPROPRIATELY THAT IS PRETTY
CONDITION ARISES THAT IS BEYOND
THEIR SCOPE THEY ARE SENDING
THAT PERSON TO THE HOSPITAL AND-
YOUR THAT THAT'S THAT'S
IMPORTANT- AS- DOCTOR WEB SAID-
THESE KIDS- IT'S YOU HAVE A
CLAIM THAT THAT FALLS WITHIN
THE LICENSED MIDWIFE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE. AND SOMETHING TO
DURING THE COURSE OF THE
DELIVERY AND SO THE MIDWIFE
APPROPRIATELY SINCE THE PERSON
TO THE HOSPITAL AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE REQUIRED
TO DO WHAT WE EXPECT THEM TO DO
AND SO THE BOARD DOESN'T
CONSIDER THAT IN AND OF ITSELF
NEGATIVE- OF COURSE QUESTIONS
ARISE. IF THEY ACTED WITHIN THE
STANDARD OF CARE ON THE TINY OF
THE TRANSFER SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DONE SOONER- SHE WAS A SENATE
APPROPRIATE CLIENTS TO TAKE
BOND TO BEGIN WITH OR TO KEEP
IT THE CONDITION AROSE. BUT THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE MAKING
TRANSFERS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
EXPECT THEM TO DO IF SOMETHING
CHANGES STAND. SHOULD SAFETY
REQUIRE THAT. AND AS A FOLLOW-
THE MIDWIFERY ACT AUTHORIZES
AUTHORIZES A LICENSE FEE TO
ATTEND CASES OF NORMAL
PREGNANCY AND CHILDBIRTH- SO
HOW DOES IT MEAN IT KINDA JUST
SEEMS TO. KIND OF CONTRADICT
ITSELF IF THERE'S A IF A
PREGNANCY CAN HAVE A
COMPLICATION AND IT WOULD IN
AND MANY DO- DOESN'T THAT KIND
OF CONTRACT DICT BE ACTED
ITSELF. WELL IT. GOES ON TO
FURTHER DEFINE NORMAL PREGNANCY
AS SAYING THAT THERE IS AN
ABSENCE OF BOTH OF THE
FOLLOWING ANY PRE EXISTING
MATERNAL DISEASE OR CONDITION
LIKELY TO AFFECT THE PREGNANCY
AND THAT'S THAT LANGUAGE THAT I
REFERRED TO BEFORE AS- BEING A
SECOND. POINT ABOUT WHAT SOME
OF THOSE TERMS ME OR- A
SIGNIFICANT THE Z. IS A- FROM
THE PREGNANCY- SO THIS IS
SOMETHING WHERE. THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO HAPPEN
TO YOU HELP THE BOARD IDEALLY-
I'M RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING- TO
WORKER. THIS LANGUAGE- TO GET
CLEAR BECAUSE THE BOARD- THE IN
CLEAR TO GO FOR WITH THE RADIO
ON THE- AND DOES ARE. THOSE ARE
CONCERNS YES AS WHAT TO EXPECT
OF US- WORKING CLASS. WITH A
MET WITH THEM. THANK YOU AND MY
SECOND QUESTION- DEAL WITH IT
INTERNATIONAL SCHOOL SO I KNOW
PRIOR TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY THE
MEDICAL RECORD THE MEDICAL
BOARD RECOGNIZED ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTY SIX
INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL SCHOOLS-
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING THERE'S
NO- THERE HASN'T REALLY BEEN A
REASSESSMENT OF THOSE. SCHOOLS
THAT WERE- I RECOGNIZE I WANTED
TO KIND OF GET AN UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT THAT WHAT THAT TIME
FRAME- FOR A RECOGNIZING IT I
MEAN TWO THOUSAND A SCHOOLS
MORE ALAS. WHAT WAS THE TIME
FRAME OF GIVING THEM
RECOGNITION AND WHAT WERE SOME
OF THE REQUIREMENTS- THAT WERE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION OR OR
CRITERIA. FOR APPROVAL AND-
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY HAS BEEN THE
OUTCOME. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
THAT AS WELL- WITH THE SHIFT TO
THE POST TRAINING MICE REQUIRE
THREE OPPOSED GRADUATE. THE.
BOARD ASKED IN THE LEGISLATURE
SHE HOW THE BOARD APPROVE.
MEDICAL SCHOOL. AND SO NOW THE
SCHOOL. IS ON. THAT WORLD
HEALTH BUT- ON FAMER LIST. IT
IS. RECOGNIZE THE BOARD NO LONG
GOES TO A HI INDEPENDENT. TO
REVIEW AND APPROVE. A PRIOR TO
THAT. THERE WERE TWO DIFFERENT
STRUCTURES. FOUR ONE FOUR AND
NONPROFIT SCHOOLS WHERE THE
PRIMARY PURPOSE WAS TO EDUCATE
CITIZENS OF THAT COUNTRY TO
PRACTICE IN THAT COUNTRY. AND
THE ONE WAS FOR PROFIT SCHOOL
WHERE THE PRIMARY PURPOSE WAS
TO EDUCATE INDIVIDUALS FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY OF YOUR
FOR PURPOSES THAT BAND. GOING
ANYWHERE TO PRACTICE AND SO THE
FOR PROFIT SCHOOLS REQUIRED A
MUCH MORE INTENSIVE REVIEW- TO
ENSURE THAT IT MET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BOARD-
THERE'S YOUR L. OF BLOOD A
DETAIL WE NEED TO WHICH HAPPY
TO GO OVER IF YOU WANT TO- IT'S
JUST THAT THAT IS NO LONGER THE
BOARD'S PROCESS. RIGHT NOW I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND WELL WHEN
DID THIS PRACTICE OF BEGAN. I
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY WAS
SAID WHEN THERE IS A SHIFT TO
POSTGRADUATE TRAINING LICENSES
AT NO LONGER GOING TO THEIR-
THE CREW WILL PROCESS FOR
SCHOOL. PRIOR TO THAT WHEN DID
IT SEEMS LIKE B. B.
INTERNATIONAL SCHOOLS- WERE
RECOGNIZED THE PROGRAM ENDED IN
TWENTY TWENTY BUT WHEN DID IT
BEGIN. OH MY GOSH I AM. WAY
BEFORE ANY OF OUR TIME HERE- IT.
STATE SENATE APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR SCHOOL CENTER IF IT WAS
RIGHT BACK DECADES. AND HOW
MANY OF THE SCHOOLS ARE STILL
RECOGNIZED. I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THAT RIGHT RIGHT THIS MOMENT
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE A LOOK
AT IT BUT I WOULD SUSPECT THAT.
ALL OF THEM WOULD BE RECOGNIZED
WITH THE CURRENT PROCESS-
BECAUSE IT'S MUCH MORE FLEXIBLE
FOR RECOGNIZING SCHOOLS AND
THAT AND THAT'S THE POINT- IT
MORE PEOPLE OPPORTUNITY TO
QUALIFY FOR LICENSURE. AND WHEN
WAS THE LAST TIME THAT THE
BOARD DID- OF REASSESSMENT. I'M
SORRY NOT A REASSESSMENT MY
APOLOGIES SO UP THE OTHER
QUESTION THAT I HAVE IN REGARDS
TO THIS IS THAT PRIOR TO
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY HOW
MANY U. S. OR CANADIAN SCHOOLS
APPLIED FOR A RECOGNITION. HOW
MANY WERE APPROVED AND HOW MANY
WERE DENIED. US OR CANADIAN
SCHOOLS YES- DOES THE BOARD
APPROVES IF THEY'RE ACCREDITED
BY. THE BETTER L. C. N. B. SO
THAT THAT THAT'S A LEVINE
AGENCIES THAT- THE BOARD RELIES
ON SO DID WE HAVE OR DID WE
HAVE A DIFFERENT PROCESS IN
PLACE FOR. APPROVAL PRIOR TO
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY.
SPOHR INTERNATIONAL MEDICAL
SCHOOLS YES BUT SAID PROCESS
HASN'T CHANGED FOR U. S. OR
CANADIAN SCHOOLS. OKAY AND. CAN
YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE SPECIAL PROGRAMS AND
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THERE'S FOR THAT THE THAT THE
MEDICAL BOARD OVERSEES IT
INCLUDES THE APPLE THE POST
GRADUATE MEDICAL SCHOOL STUDY
BY NON CITIZENS- DID YOU KNOW
WHAT DINA- CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER OF AN AMC TO A
SPONSORED INTERNATIONAL
POSITION A PARTICIPATION
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM NONCITIZENS.
I GUESS CA IN REGARDS TO THESE
FOUR DIFFERENT SPECIAL
PROGRAMS- HOW MANY HAVE BEEN
YOU KNOW GIVEN OUT AND IN YOUR
VIEW WHAT HAVE BEEN THE
BENEFITS OF THE SPECIAL
PROGRAMS TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. PARDON I'M GONNA
TURN THAT OVER TO MARINO CONNOR
CHIEF OF LICENSING. I THINK YOU
UNDER LOOKING THE NUMBERS JUST
TO SEE HOW MANY CURRENTLY HVE-
THEY'RE JUST JUST. ONE IN THE
FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY. WE
HAD TWENTY FOUR SPECIAL FACULTY
PERMITS ISSUED SELECT UNDER
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS CODE
TWENTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT. WE FIND
THE OTHER.
AND IF NOT THAT I
MEAN THAT'S OKAY WE I COULDN'T
YOU CAN PER THAT INFORMATION TO
ME AT A DIFFERENT TIME I DON'T
WANT TO HOLD EVERYONE UP AND
COMMITTEE. BOB YEAH OKAY I I'LL
DEFINITELY GET BACK TO THOSE
NUMBERS GREAT THANK YOU AND
HAVE JUST TWO QUICK QUESTIONS
SHOULD BE THE LAST THE LAST
ONES- AT. IT NOW MY NEXT
QUESTION IS REGARDS TO THIS FOR
PERMITS- THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED TO US SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY THREE- HOW ARE YOU KNOW
HOW ARE WE ENSURING THE QUALITY
OF ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTERS A
SPONSOR INDIVIDUALS THROUGH THE
SPECIAL FACT. FACULTY PERMIT
PROGRAM. SO RIGHT NOW- WE HAD
WE THERE'S SPECIFIC CRITERIA
SET OUT STATUTES FOR HOW THE-
ORGANIZATION WILL. YOU KNOW
QUALIFY AS A ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER SO THERE'S ONLY ONE
ORGANIZATIONS THUS FAR THAT HAS
EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
IDENTIFYING THEMSELVES AS AN
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER AND ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH THEM. ON
AND MAKING SURE THEY CAN
PROVIDE THE DOCUMENTATION TO
SHOW THAT THEY MEET THOSE
CRITERIA IN STATUTE. AND THE
LAST QUESTION- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD RECEIVES ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS FOR LICENSING AND
RENEWAL CYCLE TOWARDS THE
HEALTH PROFESSIONS EDUCATION.
FUND THAT THAT. GOES TO THE
PROGRAM THE STEPHEN M. THOMPSON
FOUNDATION LONG REPAYMENT
PROGRAM. IT'S THAT THE PROGRAM
ENCOURAGES NEW PHYSICIANS TO
PRACTICE AND LOW INCOME
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- DO YOU
HAVE MORE LESS AN ESTIMATE OF
HOW MUCH MONEY IS RAISED OUT OF
THOSE FEES AND- AND HOW MUCH IS
RAISED OUT OF CONTRIBUTIONS. OR
DONATIONS. I DON'T HAVE THAT IN
FRONT OF ME NO BUT WE CAN
DEFINITELY GET THAT FOR YOU
OKAY BUT THAT IS IT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU CENTER
HER TADO CENTER LEGAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING I
HAD A QUESTION SURROUNDING A
PTL THE POSTGRADUATE TRAINING
LICENSURE- SOME STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS. TO ME
ABOUT- PTL AND IT BEING
INCONSISTENT WITH FAMILY AND
MEDICAL LEAVE POLICIES
SPECIFICALLY- MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THESE THREE POLICIES
WERE ADOPTED. TO SUPPORT HEALTH
AND THE HEALTH AND WELLBEING OF
RESIDENTS. HOWEVER THE STRICT
COMPLETION OF THE TIMELINE ON
LICENSURE- DOES NOT ALLOW
RESIDENTS PARTICULARLY WOMEN
WHO ARE. IN NEED FOR THE
CONTEMPLATING HAVING CHILDREN
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR LICENSURE
WITHOUT DELAYING FELLOWSHIP AND
JOBS START STATE SPECIFICALLY I
BELIEVE THAT THE ISSUE IS. IF
YOU MISS A FEW MONTHS- WHATEVER
THE AMOUNT OF TIME IS YOU HAVE
TO ADD IT ON TO THE END. COULD
YOU. TALK TO ME A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT IF THAT IS TRUE AND
IF IT IS TRUE WHAT THE- WHAT
THE PURPOSES. IF I COULD. OKAY
SORRY HOWARD AT THIS KRAUSE. I
IT'S CERTAINLY HAS NOT BEEN THE
INTENT TO THE MEDICAL MORE AND
TO SOMEONE WHO'S DOING AN EXTRA.
THREE YEAR RESIDENTS. DO THIRTY
NINE MONTHS OF- RESIDENCY. SO
THIS AGAIN IS ANOTHER ON
CONSEQUENCE LIKE THAT
MOONLIGHTING ISSUE. THAT NEEDS
TO BE FIXED HI AND CERTAINLY IF
SOMEONE HAS MET ACGME
REQUIREMENTS AND HAS COMPLETED
THREE YEARS OF POST GRADUATE
TRAINING WHICH WAS INCLUSIVE OF
THEIR TIME OFF FOR THE JOURNAL
NEEDS ARE OTHER HEALTH NEEDS.
IT REALLY IS NOT THE INTENT OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD TO WORK
COURSE THEM IN THEIR PROGRAMS
TO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL THREE
MONTHS EFFORT RESIDENCY
TRAINING. SECOND COLLABORATION
WITH THAT WITH OTHERS ALL RIGHT
IT'S OUR INTENT TO SEE THIS
PROBLEM BE FIXED. WELL THAT'S
GREAT NEWS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA FOR
RAISING THAT VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE- MEMBER FONG.
BUT THE CARE ROTH ENSURE LOW- I
DID WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
POST GRADUATE TRAINING LESSONS
AND I BELIEVE MY ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO- ALSO
BROUGHT THIS ISSUE UP EARLY BUT
I JUST WANTED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION AS WELL I RESENTED
DURING THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE-
POSTGRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE
THE MEDICAL BOARD. WORKED WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO ENSURE PTL
RESIDENTS COULD SIT MOONLIGHT
WITHOUT IMPACTING MEDICARE
REIMBURSES I THINK THERE WAS A
ALLUSION TO THAT THIS ISSUE- IN
THE PREVIOUS ANSWER FORTY THAT
HASN'T BEEN THE CASE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- THE AREA THAT I
REPRESENT IS CONSTANTLY
CHALLENGED WITH ACCESS TO RURAL
HEALTH CARE AND PREVENT AND
PREVENTING RESIDENTS FROM
BUILDING MEDICAL- IN. HEALTH
CENTER IS JUST AN BARRIER. TO
WADA SPACE. SOLUTIONS ARE IS
THE- TO FOR. TO FIX THIS ISSUE
AND WHAT HAS BEEN THE RICHEST
FROM G. HE. YES- THIS IS MARINO
CONNOR I CAN SPEAK TO THAT-
RIGHT AS WE HAD MENTIONED WE
HAD MET WITH DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- TO YOU
KNOW FIGURE OUT WHAT THE ISSUE
WAS- WITH NOT RECOGNIZING
DETAILS- AS AN ABLE TO. A
QUALIFY FOR- PAYMENT OF MEDICAL
SERVICES AND- IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS- IT WAS- IT WAS
BROUGHT TO US THAT UNDER
FEDERAL LAW THE PTL WAS-
CONSIDERED A RESTRICTED
LICENSE- SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH- VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS-
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS- YOU KNOW.
ALL WORKING TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT THERE'S ANY POSSIBLE WAY-
IT WHETHER IT WAS A LOT CHANGE-
OR ANY ANY KIND OF
CLARIFICATION THE BOARD COULD
PROVIDE- TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN RESOLVE THIS- AND WE HAD
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM I
BELIEVE THERE ARE. THERE WAS
EVEN SOME- LANGUAGE PROPOSED
AND WE WERE LOOKING AT IT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO SEE IF THAT WOULD
RESOLVE THE ISSUE BUT- THEY DID
NOT APPEAR THAT THAT WAS GOING
TO RESOLVE IT- ACCORDING TO DH
CS- SO YOU KNOW WE JUST
CONTINUE TO. TRY TO FIND
AVENUES FORWARD- YOU KNOW AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE YOU KNOW
HOW BEST TO RESOLVE THIS
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
HUGE ISSUE- AND IT NEEDS TO BE
A NEED TO BE RESOLVED. SO IF
YOU DO MIND- FOLLOW I GUESS
MMHM MAYBE CAN CUT OF DEVIL
DEEPER- I UNDERSTAND IT IS TOP.
AND TRYING TO OUT THE SOLUTION
BUT WHAT ARE THE PROS. IS WHAT.
D. H. C. S. PROPOSED WOULD HAS
THE MEDICAL. BOARD PROPOSED-
COMMITTEE IS THE GULF BETWEEN
THE TWO THAT ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS PRETTY LARGE FOR A
WE CLOSE TO SOMETHING IS ARE
SOME COMMON GROUND HERE. YEAH I
MEAN WHAT WE'VE LOOKED AT IS-
IS IT A MATTER OF- YOU KNOW HOW
IN THE LOT. WE DEFINE WHAT
OPPOSE GREATER TRAINING
LICENSES AS FAR AS ITS
EQUIVALENTS TO A FULL AND
UNRESTRICTED PHYSICIANS.
LICENSE SO- YOU KNOW I DON'T
HAVE THE LANGUAGE IN FRONT OF
ME BUT SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
THAT WAS PROPOSED BUSINESS SOME
WAY WE CAN WORD IT. SO IT'S
CLEAR THAT THEY HAVE THE SAME.
ROUGHLY THE SAME- AND
DISCREPANCY THAT THEY CAN STILL
PRACTICE- YOU KNOW MEDICINE IN
THE SAME SKILL. JUSTWITHIN
THEIR THEIR RESIDENCY PROGRAM-
SO YOU KNOW WE WE'RE WE'VE
WE'VE- TRYING TO FIND- WORKING
WITH DH CS WHAT ELSE WE CAN DO
WHAT OTHER LANGUAGE WE CAN
PROPOSE- YOU KNOW WHERE. THEY
WOULD CONSIDER A PTL AN
UNRESTRICTED. LICENSE OKAY. TO
ADD TO YES. WE'VE BEEN BLINDS.
BY THIS ISSUE. HI THIS STATE OF
THE- WE'RE ACTIVELY REACHING
OUT TO YOU- TEN TO. OTHER
STATES. THAT ALL REQUIRE THAN
YEAR COURSE GRADUATE TRAINING.
HI AND DO NOT APPEAR TO HAVE
THE SAME MOONLIGHTING ISSUE.
WITH THAT T. OF OUR DISCOVERY
IS TO LEARN HOW THIS PROBLEM
HAS BEEN AVOIDED OR OVERCOME
AND IN OTHER STATES AND
HOPEFULLY TO BE ABLE TO.
INSTITUTE THE SAME PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I I'D LIKE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK
THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS REVEALED
OR EXACERBATED WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW THE CENTER VALLEY WHICH IS
OUR OUR HEALTHCARE SHOULD-
PERSONNEL SHORTAGE. AND SO- I
CERTAINLY AM AND WATCHING THIS
VERY CLOSELY AND I APPRECIATE
IF YOU COULD PROVIDE ANY
SPECIFICS- AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR. THANK
YOU OF MEMBER FONG. COLLEAGUES
ANY OTHER QUITE. COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SEEING NO MICROPHONES
UP. I MAY MMHM MEMBERS OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA I
MAY HAVE A REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT COST RECOVERY
BUT I'LL AND I'LL IS THAT
OFFLINE IF YOU CAN PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION THAT WILL BE. OF
FINE. LET'S SO LET'S PROCEED TO
TAKE TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA ISSUES.
LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY AND THERE
ARE NONE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT- YOU SEE NO WITNESSES
THERE. THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. REGARDING THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WE
WILL BE ABLE TO BEGIN. SURE IF
YOU ARE READY TO MAKE A COMMENT
YOU PUSH ONE AND THEN ZERO TO
GET IN THE QUEUE. AND I'LL GIVE
YOU A LINE NUMBER. ONE AND THEN
IT ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF THE- PRETTY GO AHEAD
LINE IS. OUR GOOD MORNING WAS A
WITH AS YOU COW- LEAD RAPPER BY
SIX OUT. RESIDENTS AN INTERN
ACROSS STATE- CAL AND WE LIKE
TO THINK THE- COMMITTEE MET AND
STOP THE WORK ON THIS ON SITE
PROCESS. AND THE CONTINUE
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT PATIENTS
AND CONSUMERS. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
INCLUSION IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER ABOUT THE MANY ISSUES
THAT COME UP AROUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PPL. AND
THAT IS REALLY OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN- THE BILLY TO MOVE MY
IS CRITICAL TO MANY RESIDENTS-
SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE ENDS MEET
DURING A TIME WHEN THEY'RE
TRYING TO PAY BACK A LARGE
STUDENT LOANS- MEET. ME HERE
WRITING HOUSING COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S OVER THOSE
REASONS WE- YOU KNOW WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND OTHERS TO
FIND A SOLUTION BUT AT THIS
TIME THE OSCAR- THAT PEOPLE
THAT THIS COMMITTEE REVEALS THE
PPL. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. IN THE NEXT
WEEK I. SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR IN THE- THANK MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MEGAN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF CAROL PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATE. AS HE
HEARD THIS MORNING OPPOSED
GRADUATE LICENSE REQUIREMENTS
WHICH WERE EFFECTIVE IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY YEAR RESULTING.
IN A VARIETY OF SIGNIFICANT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
ARE IMPACTING ACCESS TO CARE
THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS PROVIDE
THAT MEDICAID PROVIDERS MUST
NOT HAVE CURRENT LIMITATIONS ON
THEIR LICENSES AND AS NOTED IN
YOUR COMMITTEE BACKGROUND
DOCUMENT. THE PPL IS INTENDED
TO BE AN UNRESTRICTED LICENSE
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THIS ACT.
HOWEVER OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES WHEN REVIEWING THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS HAVE
INTERPRETED THE PTL AT THE
RESTRICTED LICENSE THEREBY PTL
HOLDER THERE IN ELIGIBLE TO
ENROLL IN. AB MEDICAL PROVIDERS
AND BILL MEDIC. CAL WHILE
MOONLIGHTING. ACT THE RESIDENTS
OF TO GET ADDITIONAL. AND A-
WERE ALSO AWARE THAT SAMPLE TO
CLIMB BACK. PRETTY A. X. HEARD
THE YOU HEARD OF THE PTL
RESTRICT. WHICH MEANS OF HAVING
A NEGATIVE ON PATIENTS WITH.
SUBSTANCE PART- TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PPL RIGHT
AND THESE CHALLENGES- AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE- WE'VE HAD
WITH THE COMMITTEE BUT THIS.
THAT THE MEDICAL AND H. U. S.
AND THIS IS FOR ALL TWO EVEN
CREE AND ONE. ARE PRE DATE BUT
WE HAVE FOUND THROUGH THOSE.
THAT IN A MINUTE SIXTEEN
UNLIKELY AT THE P. CREE LIMIT.
WHICH IS WHY THE BEEN WORK THE
RIGHT THE TO OF THE- POSITION
LICENSE. PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PEACE.
WERE ENCOURAGED TO HEAR THE
CALL THAT AND THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND THE STAFF AND- WITH ISSUE
ADDRESSED. TO MAINTAIN ACT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. WILL GO TO
THEIR LINE OF SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD DO I IS OPEN. THANK YOU
SHARE THE NUMBER SENATE HE
CANNOT BEHALF CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY. WE
APPRECIATE THE CALL CLASS TODAY
MUCH SO ALSO. THE FACT WRITTEN
PAPER IN THE EMPLOY WORK HE'S
COMMITTEES TAKE ON A PART. PLAN
COMMITTEE OF THE THAT PROCESS.
HOWEVER CONTENT EDUCATION THE
POST THREE LIFE IN WE ARE OTHER
CRY CARE AND MIGHT HELP
PROVIDER. YOU WANT. ON AND
SHALL TO TRAINING AND
ESTABLISHING BECAUSE THIS AND-
WE CAN BACK ON PAPER EXCELLENT
JOB OF CAPS MANY THESE ON AND
CONSEQUENCES. DURING THE O
COURSE THE WORK BOTH BE PIECE
THAT BOARDS DONE TO WITH THESE.
I WANTED TO FOCUS ON THE
INCOMING THE- LIKE FROM TIME WE
POLICY NOT TO YOUNG CUTTING
YOUR PAN AND COULD. YOU'RE
READY OF RESIDENTS ARE AT THE
EARLY PART OF THEIR ADULTHOOD.
POLICY CAN HAPPEN DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT ON WOMEN IN PARTICULAR
IF THEY NEED TO TAKE TIME OFF
TO START AMAM. CRITIC EARLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND OTHER
CARE GIVING RESPONSIBILITIES TO
BE PHASED IN UNTIL HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES OF PROVIDING CARE
TO PATIENTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
OR ORGANIZATIONS IN THE INDIAN
MEDICAL BOARD STOCKTON DONE TO
FIND SOLUTIONS TO THESE
BARRIERS CLOSE TO TWO YEARS
NOW. EACH PROBLEM THAT WE FACE
REMAINS UNRESOLVED BECAUSE
OTHER ENTITIES YOU THE PTL HAS
RESTRICTED LICENSE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE HAVE COME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT WE MUST RETAIN
THE PTL AND WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
DO SO THROUGH THE SUNSET REVIEW
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SURE MEMBERS TO MADDEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS I LIKE
TO ALSO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR TIME INTO RIGHT
UP IN THE ANALYSIS ON THE POST
GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE
ISSUES AS WELL AS THE COMMENTS
TODAY FROM BOTH MEMBERS AS WELL
AS FROM THE MEDICAL BOARD
RECOGNIZING THE URGENCY AROUND
THIS MEASURE. WE ALONG WITH THE
OTHER GROUPS THAT JUST I'VE
SPOKEN ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
MULTIPLE ISSUES RELATED TO THE
POST GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE
QUICKLY FOCUS ON TO WHAT ARE
THE IMPACTS ON MOOD LIGHTING
AND THE ABILITY TO OBTAIN AN X.
WAIVER. FOR EMERGENCY MEDICINE
RESIDENTS AFTER THEIR FIRST
TO FIND OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK
SHIFTS THAT OTHER EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS URGENT CARE CENTERS
OR CLINICS OVER THE REMAINING
THREE YEARS OF THE WRENCHING
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS MEDICAL
STUDENTS ARE STARTING AT
SIGNIFICANT WITH SIGNIFICANT
STUDENT LOANS AND THEIR INCOME.
FROM RESIDENTS HE DOESN'T GO
VERY FAR. HAS THE ADDITIONAL
IMPACT REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
POSITIONS WHO ARE WANTING TO
WORK SHIFTS. THAT ARE MANY
TIMES DIFFICULT FOR HOSPITALS
URGENT CARE CENTERS AND
CLINICS. TO FIND POSITIONS TO
COVER. TO PROVIDE SOME
PERSPECTIVE THIRD TWENTY TWO
EMERGENCY MEDICINE RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
ROUGHLY ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED EMERGENCY MEDICAL
RESIDENTS I'M PARTICIPATING IN
THOSE PROGRAMS SO THESE ARE ALL
FOLKS WHO ARE LOOKING TO WORK.
IN THOSE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NOT ABLE
TO DO AT THIS TIME THE SECOND
ISSUE WE HAVE IS WITH THE-
OBTAINING AN EX WEBER HAS
MENTIONED WE'VE APPLIED. AND
BEEN REJECTED FROM SAMPSON ONE
OF PLANNING FOR THE X. WAIVER-
THIS IS BECOME A AND A COMMON
IMPORTANT TOOL ALLOWING
EMERGENCY MEDICINE. PHYSICIANS
TO START PATIENTS ON MEDICALLY
ASSISTED TREATMENT FOR THE
PERSON'S ADDICTION CHALLENGES
THIS RESTRICTION LIMITS THE
ABILITY TO RESIDENTS TO PROVIDE
CARE TO PATIENTS IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS IN WHICH THEY'RE
WORKING AND TRAINING AND ALL
ALSO REPRESENTS ANOTHER BARRIER
TO MOOD LIGHTING. FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE ASKING THE
POSTGRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE
TO BE RESCINDED. AND WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL OF YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU JUST A
AS A NOTE FOR THOSE WAITING ON
THE LINE WE- HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE INDIVIDUALS WAITING IN
THAT NUMBER TENDS TO GROW I'M
PRETTY LIBERAL IN TERMS OF
ALLOWING. COMMENT BUT I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU TRY TO LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS AND- IF THAT DOESN'T
WORK WE'LL HAVE TO REVISIT THE
ISSUE. OF MADAME MODERATOR NEXT
PLEASE. WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY THAT MY NUMBER EIGHTY.
HELLO HELLO PLEASE PROCEED. HI-
I AM ONE PERSON PARENTS MEDICAL
ERRORS IN CALIFORNIA JUST
COMMIT DIFFERENT TOPICS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME INVESTIGATING
THE BORDER INTENT THAT REVIEW
AT THAT PIVOTAL PIVOTAL POINT
HISTORY YOU HAVE THE OPTION TO
CHANGE THE DIRECTION OF MEDICAL
HARM IN CALIFORNIA TOWARDS
PATIENT SAFETY REACTIVE VERSUS
PROACTIVE RIGHT VERSUS WRONG AT
THE CLOVERS. WITH UNETHICAL THE
CHOICE IS YOURS. I THINK WISELY
OUR LIVE DEPEND. SO I THE
MEDICAL HE CAN ONLY YEARS OF MY
LIFE NEW DOLLARS I EXCEPT FOR A
FEW YEARS MA'AM. MA'AM INJECT
HELLO HEY MA'AM. I CANNOT HEAR
YOU NORM CAN I YOU SO YOU'RE
GOING HAVE TO DOWN AND YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO SPEAK LOUDLY
AND CLEARLY BECAUSE WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO HEAR YOU BUT
PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF OUR TIME
LIMITATION SO. IF YOU COULD HIT
YOUR HIGH POINTS THAT WOULD BE
GREAT LOUD AND CLEAR PLEASE
THANK YOU. OKAY IT DOESN'T
MATTER HOW MEDICALLY YOU
SOMEBODY IS I CHANGED SYSTEM
WIDE HEALTH CARE POLICY. AND I
COULD NOT OBTAIN MEDICAL CARE I
WOULD UNITE CARE. FOR THREE
YEARS. I DID NOT REPORT TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD COULD I WOULD
FALL INTO THE YELLOWSTONE AT
TEN THOUSAND I'M HEARD CASES.
SO IT'S CONCERNING THAT WE HAVE
NOWHERE TO TURN THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO WAY FOR ME TO
TURN IN CALIFORNIA. A MEDICAL
BOARD BOARD BLAMES LEGISLATORS
FOR THE SHORTCOMINGS SAYING
IT'S A LAW THAT RESTRICTS THEM.
AND ALSO YOU ARE APPOINT PEOPLE
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD TO
ADVOCATE FOR MICRO. SAYS THAT
DOING A PREDATOR TO THE MIRACLE
MEDICAL BOARD THEY CALLED ME
HOMELESSNESS POVERTY EMOTIONAL
ANGUISH AND SOME PEOPLE HAVE
COMMITTED SUICIDE OVER MY CRUSH
BUT IT'S OKAY FOR THE PEOPLE TO
THE BOARD. INSTEAD TO DOCTORS
THAT HAVE BENEFITTED INTEREST
IN PATIENT SAFETY AND ADVOCACY.
REMOVE THE MEMBERS THAT DO NOT
FOLLOW THE GUIDELINES IT WILL
MEMBERS EQUAL MEMBERS A PUBLIC
PERSON DOCTORS. I HAVE MEMBERS
TRAINED AND PATIENT SAFETY AND
EFFICACY. WEBER MEMBERS TO BE
TRAINED AND PATIENT SAFETY. AND
WE NEED MORE MONEY TO PREVENT
THINGS FROM HAPPENING IN THE
FIRST PLACE IS THERE ANYTHING.
BEING DONE TO STOP THE EARTH
BEFORE THEY HAPPEN IF YOUR
DEBIT DATABASE TO PREVENT
RECURRENT ERRORS. ADVANI WHO
ACTIVELY. AND LASTLY IN. TEN
MILLION DOLLARS HAVE BEEN SPENT
ON A BOOK CERVANTES ADVERSE
DRUG EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
ANOTHER DRESS- TRONG AT THE
DRESS IN FACT THE BREAKING YET
THE SAME PEOPLE ARE LIT
TRAUMATIZING IN THE POPULATION
THE MOST POPULAR BONTA BROUGH
POPULATED THE TO EXPERIENCE
MEDICAL ERRORS. A TRAUMA. ANY
OTHER PART BECAUSE WHY HOME
WITH ACTION WOULD BE TAKEN. BUT
NOBODY'S DOING ANY ABOUT THE
TRUMP THE HARM WE TRY WE EXPECT
OF MEDICAL HARM. AND I WOULD IF
SOMETHING WAS DONE TO ADDRESS
THIS. AND I ALSO SENT YOU A LOT
CHANGE TOPIC DR BREEN A BARBER
MENTAL HEALTH FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS THE NATIONAL LAW AND
EVERY NIGHT THE CLERK. BURKE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS TRAUMA. ONE
MORE COMMENT. HEALTH WORKERS
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE COMPLIANT IN
THE BOARD MANDATED TREATMENT
FOR COMMON. BUT FROM A VERY
HARD TO WORK WITH AND IT'S VERY
LIKELY THE BOARD DESCRIBED
TREATMENT. IT ALSO TRAUMATIZING
AND UNIQUE PROBLEM THERAPIST ON
THE BOARD TO UNDERSTAND TRAUMA
WORKING WITH IT. AND SECONDLY
DOCTORS GO THROUGH TRAUMA
THERAPY THAT MAY CAUSE MORE
PROBLEMS IN THE STATE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING
NEXT PLEASE. WE HAVE A AYE
NUMBERTWENTY ONE THAT BY
NUMBER TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU
RIGHT CENTER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO LICENSE PLATE
WITH REPORTS ON MULTIPLE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY
AND AS MENTIONED ABOUT EIGHT
YEARS AGO. LIKE MIDWIVES
AUTHORIZED TO PRACTICE ABOUT
POSITION TO PROVISIONS LIKE
MIDWIVES ARE GRANTED
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE THEY ARE
REGULATED AS THEY ARE TODAY BY
THE MEDICAL BOARD USED TO WITH
ME WITH REVISED WE COMMITTEE.
AT THAT TIME STAKEHOLDERS
AGREED TO EXPAND THIS GOAL
BECAUSE THE MEDICAL BOARD WOULD
RETAIN REGULATORY AUTHORITY
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROFESSION.
WELL LIFE MIDWIVES MAY HAVE
BEEN IN A TORTILLA THE PRACTICE
OF MIDWIFERY CAN AND DOES
SIGNIFICANTLY IN IRAQ WITH THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN PATIENTS
REQUIRE TRANSFER TO THE
NATION'S IN HOSPITALS PREPARED
AS BEYOND THEIR TRAINING AND
COMPETENCE. BASED ON THIS
UNDERSTANDING ACRE CONTENT
ESTABLISHING THE INDEPENDENT
BOARD COLLECTIONS IS WHITE AT
THIS TIME SHOULD NOT BE
CONTEMPLATED WITHOUT A
CONCURRENT REVIEW OF THE
QUALIFICATIONS AND SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FOR LICENSED MIDWIVES.
THAT PROTECTS PATIENTS AND PER
THE COURT BY THE PRACTICE WE
SIT BETWEEN POSITIONS IN MY
MIDWIVES. JUST LAST YEAR A
PUBLIC DILIGENTLY WITH A
CERTIFIED NURSE CERTIFIED NURSE
MIDWIVES FUND SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN DIED WITH REVIEW NURSE
MADE WITH MIDLIFE SCULPTING
GRANTED THEM A LEVEL
INDEPENDENCE WITHIN A SPECIFIC
FRAMEWORK AND WHEN TO
COLLABORATE WITH PHYSICIANS
INCLUDING ATTORNEY TO BE FACTS.
WE BELIEVE SB TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN WAS PASSED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE CAN BE A MODEL IN
RELATED COLLECTIONS MIDWIVES.
AS WELL FOR ALL THESE REASONS A
COGNOS SUPPOSED THE SON PRICE
ELECTIONS MIDWIFERY BOARD THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. WHY NOT. THIRTY
THAT'S FINE NUMBER THERE WE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MORE- I AM
TO OUR THE IN CREATING A BE
PLACED INTO THE QUESTIONS
NUMBER THREE BY BEING IN THE
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA SUNSET DEL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU PLEASE. WE
HAVE NUMBER FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MY NAME IS MONIQUE I
AM FROM BIG AND I'M WITH THE
FOR PATIENTS THAT BY
REPRESENTATIVES ARE SENATE I'M-
COMMITTEE MEMBER SENATOR
MELISSA HURTADO AND ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY SALAS. THE
BOARD PAID FOR ALL OF THE
TRANSITION COSTS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE PROSECUTIONS FOR
LICENSE TO RENDER REDEDICATION
AND PROBATION WHAT OTHER BOARDS
INCLUDING THE DENTAL BOARD AND
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
WE COVER THOSE COSTS. WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATION
REQUIRING THE BOARD TO
IMPLEMENT COST RECOVERY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD ALSO APPROVE%
THE BOARD'S RECOMMENDATION FOR
LICENSING FEE INCREASE. THE
FINES WOULD ELIMINATE FINANCING
AS AN EXCUSE FOR THE BOARD'S
FAILURES THEY WOULD ALSO REDUCE
ENFORCEMENT TIMELINES BECAUSE
THERE WOULD BE FINANCIAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR LICENSE YOU TO
DRAG OUT AND REASONABLE AND
HELPS. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU HI MY NAME'S NICOLE
ORIGINALLY AND I'M CALLING TO
ASK THAT THE LANGUAGE CREATING
A LICENSED MIDWIFE BOARD BE
INCLUDED. IN THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA REVIEW FOUND
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CENTER ON THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CENTER
FOR AS MEMBERS IS VERY AND SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY AND A
CONSTITUENT OF SOME OF THE
WILK. I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF OUR FAMILY ANOTHER
PATIENT WHO SUFFERED HARM DUE
TO MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE AND IN
SUPPORT OF THE FAIRNESS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE FACT. TODAY I
WANT TO FOCUS. ON THE A POST
GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE KEY.
ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP
TODAY. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. OUR SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER JORDAN ONE MONTH
SHY OF GRADIENT BIRTHDAY AND
TWO MONTHS BEFORE HER HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION. DIED AS AN
EGREGIOUS MEDICAL ARE RESULT OF
EGREGIOUS MEDICAL NEGLIGENCE
CAUSED BY AN UNLICENSED MEDICAL
STUDENTS. IN TODAY'S
ENVIRONMENT THAT STUDENTS WOULD
HAVE HELD A PCL. WORKING WITH
DIAGNOSED WITH BLOOD CLOTS BY
THIS UNLICENSED MEDICAL STUDENT.
SHE HAD BLOOD CLOTS IN HER
ABDOMEN. AND INSTEAD OF
REQUESTING CONSULATES AS HE
SHOULD HAVE HE CALLED IN
MEDICAL STATUS TWO ATTENDING
PHYSICIANS WHO MAY HAVE NOT
BEEN ON PREMISES. IN VIOLATION
OF THE ACGME AND HOSPITAL
POLICY. HE WAS A STUDENT IN AN
ACCREDITED PROGRAM. IN A
LICENSED FACILITY DID NOT
PROVIDE ANY OVERSIGHT TO OUR
DAUGHTER. JORDAN'S BLOOD CLOTS
WERE IN HER VEINS TO HER LABOR
THE VEINS TO HER SPLEEN WITH A
HISTORY OF A LARGE PLANE FOR
THREE YEARS. THEY WERE ALSO IN
THE VEINS TO HER INTESTINES.
SHE ALSO HAD INDICATIONS OF
CIRRHOSIS. AND SEVERE INFECTION
THAT RESULTED TO INFECTION
TRAVELING TO HER BRAIN THROUGH
HER V. P. SHOT. THIS MEDICAL
STUDENT FAILED TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT HE WAS NOT SUPERVISED.
AND ACCORDING TO THIS MEDICAL
BOARD WAS IN VIOLATION OF STATE
LAW BY PRACTICING MEDICINE
WITHOUT A LICENSE. NOT ONLY IN
RESULT OF THE MEDICAL BOARD
STATEMENTS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AT KNOWLEDGE SB SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT WHICH DEVELOPED
THE POSTGRADUATE TRAINING
LICENSE. MEMBERS OF THIS.
TODAY'S MEMBERS INDICATED THAT
THEY WANTED TO ALLOW. A POST
GRADUATE TRAINING LICENSE TO
ACT AS AN UNRESTRICTED LICENSE
AND IN THE SAME MANNER AS IF A
PHYSICIAN OR A TRAINING STUDENT
IS A FULLY LICENSED INDIVIDUAL
WHICH NOT ONLY DEFEATS THE
PURPOSE OF A TRAINING LICENSE
TO GAIN MORE EXPERIENCE TO BE
ABLE TO PRACTICE ON THEIR OWN.
BUT IT ALSO PUTS COMMUNITIES AT
RISK. ASSEMBLY COOLEY I RECALL
SENATOR ARAMBULA INDICATING
THAT. WE NEED MORE DOCTORS AND
THAT THE UNRESTRICTED NATURE OF
THE PPL WOULD BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT SOCIOECONOMIC
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. TO
ME THAT MEANS THIS COMMITTEE
AND MEMBERS. DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERN FOR PATIENT SAFETY FOR
LESS ADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WHICH TYPICALLY ARE OF LOWER
INCOME. APOLOGIES ARE THERE IS
ZERO ACCOUNTABILITY BEFORE THE
PPL AND EVEN AFTER THERE ARE NO
ASSURANCES HOLDERS OF THE PPL
ARE NOT CONTINUING TO VIOLATE
THE LAW THEY ARE NOT FULLY
LICENSED NOR SHOULD THEY BE
CONSIDERED FULLY LICENSED. THEY
SHOULD REQUIRE FURTHER
RESTRICTIONS. THEY SHOULD HAVE
FURTHER RESTRICTIONS WITH THE
ACGME WHICH REQUIRE SUPERVISION
UPHOLDERS OF THE PPL. THERE MAY
BE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
THE PTO HOWEVER DON'T QUESTION
YOUR REVIEW DON'T RUSH IN YOUR
JUDGMENT TO ALLOW CHANGES TO
MAKE THIS AN UNRESTRICTED
LICENSE AS IF THEY WERE FULLY
LICENSED PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS. SIMPLY BECAUSE THESE
INDIVIDUALS EXPRESSED CONCERN
ABOUT MAKING MONEY OR BEING
ABLE TO BILL MEDICARE OR MEDI
CAL SHOULD NOT BE A REASON TO
UNRESTRICTED TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS. THINK OF JORDAN.
JORDAN HAS THE RIGHT TO LIVE.
SHE HAD THE RIGHT TO BE SEEN BY
A LICENSED PHYSICIAN AND
MEDICAL STUDENT WHO YOU GUYS
WOULD HAVE GRANTED A PTO WITH
ZERO OVERSIGHT. WE NEED MEMBERS
OF THE MEDICAL BOARD. TO BE
ABLE TO. HOLD THESE INDIVIDUALS
ACCOUNTABLE WE NEED
TRANSPARENCY FOR HOLDING THESE
INDIVIDUALS ACCOUNTABLE. WE
NEED A PUBLIC MEMBER MAJORITY
OF THE MEDICAL BOARD SO THAT
WAY WE CAN ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND NOT ALLOWING
DOCTORS TO CONTINUE POLICING
THEMSELVES FOR THESE ACTIONS. I
WISH THAT YOU GUYS WOULD.
CONSIDER. THE VIEWS ON LIFE
EXPERIENCE WHETHER YOU GIVE
THEM A POSTGRADUATE TRAINING
LICENSE OR NOT THEY ARE NOT
FULLY LICENSED. THEY ARE NOT
THE SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
PRACTICE MEDICINE WITHOUT
OVERSIGHT MOONLIGHTING OR
OTHERWISE. I HOPE YOU TAKE THIS
INTO CONSIDERATION AND I HOPE
YOU REMEMBER JORDAN WHEN YOU TO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MA'AM WE'RE VERY SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. AMANDA MODERATOR
NOW WILL NOT A LINE NUMBER.
PLEASE GO ONLINE OF A THIRTY
TWO YEAR OLD COMPLAINT PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS KAREN CORRECT AND
I'M CALLING AFFECT LANGUAGE
CREATING A LICENSED MIDWIFE
BOARD BE INCLUDED IN THE
MEDICAL BOARD CALIFORNIA IF YOU
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. FILLING NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR GOING TO. CRISTINA PLEASE
PROCEED. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA FOLEY AND I'M CALLING.
OUR THAT THE LANGUAGE ON THE
PROCREATING LIGHT RIGHT BOARD
BE INCLUDED AND THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THAT
REVIEWED DOWN THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. GOING ON THE
LINE FIFTEEN YEAR OLD ONE OF
THE THINGS. HI GOOD MORNING CAN
YOU HEAR ME PERFECTLY PLEASE
PROCEED. ALL RIGHT I WENT FOR A
MEDICALLY RECOMMENDED BREAST
REDUCTION DURING WHICH SAW
BURGER STAB ME DOZENS OF TIMES
IN THE MUTILATING FALL. DOCTORS
AGREE THE AMOUNT AND SEVERITY
OF THE INJURIES BURGER COGNATE
INDICATE THIS COULD ONLY BE THE
RESULT OF RECKLESSNESS MALICE
OR GROSS NEGLIGENCE. THERE WAS
NO VALID MEDICAL REASON CONSENT
SCIENCE OR MITIGATING
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THIS ATTACK.
SO WHY IS SOBRE CRISTO LICENSE.
HE SHOULD BE IN JAIL LIKE THE
POLICEMAN WHO KNEELED ON GEORGE
FOR ITS NECK. THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND LAWS REGULATING THE
PRACTICE OF MEDICINE USED TO BE
ABOUT TREATING ILLNES AND
DISEASE. WHY DO YOU PROTECT
DOCTORS WHO SCAMMON BATTER
LARSON AND LIVE. PEOPLE
SCAPEGOAT SHE CLINICS IN
TIJUANA HOWEVER LICENSE
SURGEONS IN RECEIPT CALIFORNIA
AMBULATORY CENTERS DO THE MOST
HARM. WITH YOUR SUPPORT
RESURGENT CREATED PLASTIC
SURGERY GENOCIDE WORLDWIDE. THE
OFFENDERS CREATE RECORDS FULL
OF LIES AND OMISSIONS. AFTER
MEDICAL HARM COLLUDING DOCTORS
REFUSE TO DO APPROPRIATE TO THE
CALL TO THEM AND INSTEAD LET I
NEEDED I NEEDED PSYCHIATRISTS
MISDIAGNOSIS AND MISTREATMENT
THEM CAUSING UNTENABLE
BUFFERING. MY CIVIL CASES LOTS
BECAUSE TERRY DOBRO AN EXPERT
FOR THIS BOARD LIED. TO
TRANSLATE THE JURY TO BELIEVE
THE GROWTH MEDICAL BOARD
CREDENTIALS MEAN HE'S THE
TRUSTED EXPERT. IT'S BECAUSE OF
THE DISHONEST HISTORY OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD THAT. ALLOWS
GAMBLING ASSAULT I WAS
MEDICALLY HARMED AND ALSO
BECAUSE OF THEM I WAS DENIED
RESTITUTION. VICTIM THE LEFT
DESTITUTE AND ABANDONED
CALIFORNIA. I RAN SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESSES THAT I LOVE TO HELP
PEOPLE BEFORE BURGER DISABLED
ME. I'VE LOST OVER SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN INCOME AND
COUNTING AND NOW WITH
HOMELESSNESS. I'D LIVED ON TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN DOLLARS A
WEEK FOR NEARLY TEN YEARS COULD
YOU. CRAP DANGERS MEDICAL AND
OUT A WAY TO HELP VICTIMS LIKE
MASON FINANCIALLY AFTER THE
HARM AND CORRUPTION TAKES
EVERYTHING. THE MEDICAL BOARD
EXPERT MY CASE ACTED
DISHONESTLY IT SHOULD BE LOOKED
INTO WHO THAT WAS AND HOW THIS
HAPPENED BECAUSE MY CASE WAS SO
SEVERE THAT YOU'RE LETTING THIS
GO BY. I KNOW YOU'RE HIDING A
HORRIBLE ATROCITIES GO BY AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
QUIT THE MIDWIVES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU FOR GOING OUT TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE IS GOING.
TO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
TERRY DAVIS I AM A LICENSED
MIDWIFE IN SAN DIEGO- LIKE TO
AT STATE HOUSE EXCITED I AM
THAT DOCTOR WEBER HAS JOINED
THIS COMMITTEE I WELCOME DR
WEBER IT'S GREAT TO SEE ITSELF
INDIAN UNFOLLOW REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. ON THE
COMMITTEE- I AM CALLING TO
SUPPORT ADDING A SUNRISE OF THE
MIDWIFERY BOARD INTO LANGUAGE
FOR THE CONCERT REVIEW FILL UP
THE MEDICAL BOARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A ABOUT
TWENTY SIX CALLERS STILL. ON
THE LINE SO WE'RE GOING TO
START. AS CAN YOU DELIVER YOUR
COME TO OF. A MINUTE IF YOU
COULD NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF ON THE LINE
NUMBER FIFTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING I'M JOHN CAMPBELL
FOUNDER AND CEO WOULD BE BACK
BACK INTO TIME TO GOOD FOR
CLIENTS I REPRESENT THOUSANDS
OF BREAKING FAMILY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHEN I EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT OH SIX
IT'S AMENDED TO INCLUDE
LANGUAGE CREATING A LIGHT.
WHITE FORD. I THINK IMPORTANT
TO DRAFT HAVE WHEN WE ARE GIVEN.
FEEDBACK WITH A LIGHT MIDWIFE
THE STATE WILL HAVE POLICIES.
BANNING BE BACK FOR WOMEN
UNDERGO ANOTHER PREPARING AND
WOULD LET'S NOT A INDICATE.
WHAT DID DOES IT MAKE IT
EVERYONE TO REPEAT JERRY IT. BE
CLEAR THOSE WHO HAVE A REPEAT
VARIANT OF TIME MORE LIKELY
THOSE TWO GUYS THEN THE WHO
PLAN TO BE BACK. I DO AS ONLY
MAIN DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
MATERNAL CARE CLOUT AT EIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA SEEING A OF
HYSTERECTOMY. A CREDO AND
SIGNIFICANT BLOOD LOSS YOU
MULTIPLE CRY TO TEARING THEM.
BOB THE BIGGEST RISK OF THE FOR
EXPERIENCE IS THE REPEAT JUST
IT. THE ONE WOULD THINK IF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF TO AND-
SUPPORTS ARE. AS THEY DO AND
REPEAT TO CARRY A CHECK
CONTRIBUTED ACCEPT MATERNAL
DEATHS MORBIDITY. EVERYONE
WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO PLAN
TO BE BACK AND AVOID
UNNECESSARY SURGERY. THE TRUTH
IS THEY DON'T. THE TRIGGER 20%
OF CALIFORNIA HARPER REQUIRE
REPEAT AREA FOR ANYWAY WITH A
PRIOR CARRYING. THE PEOPLE WHO
BURKE COULD BE FACILITY ARE NOT.
ALLOW TO HAVE VAGINAL AFTER. AS
A RESULT THE REPEAT JERRY
RATING HOW. EACH 5% EIGHT FIVE
DESPITE A CAR BY ONE. ACT
BECAUSE HOSPITAL BE BACK TO GET.
IF IMPOSSIBLE FOR OUR-
ESPECIALLY RURAL. AND RESULT
NEW YORK BASED CHOICE VIDAK THE
LIGHTS MIDWIFE OR DISCOUNT. IF
WHICH WOULD BE BACK A LIGHT
GOOD WIFE. AND HOSPITAL BE
COULD NOT OPTION. ACTUALLY FOR
WITH IF YOU WANT YOUR MONEY
REPEAT TO CARRYING. INCREASING
RISK THAT COME CRIME EXPERIENCE.
OR INTO ONE OF. HOME BIRTH WHEN
THEY DELIVER WITH OUR I NEED Y.
WORKING PRESENT. IT TO HELP.
THROUGH ITS LOG OR. MARGARET TO
BE A GOOD WITH LOCAL BE THE
DURING TAX. WE OBJECTED SHOULD
BE THE MORE. NOT LIKE. EVERY
VIDAK. THOUSAND FAMILIES WE
REPRESENT- DO SUPPORT UNLIKE
WHY CORD CREEVEY EUROPE. TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE FOR
PEOPLE CAN ACCESS. AND THE REST
OF THE. ONE TWENTY NINE EURO
PLEASE GO TO. MY NAME IS
MICHELLE WELBORN I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M CALLING TO
ASK ABOUT LANGUAGE CREATING A
LIFE COMMITMENT CORD BEING IN
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD
CONTENT READY NOW THANK YOU FOR
YOU MA'AM PERFECT TECH. THANKS
FOR MOVING ON A LOT TWENTY TWO
YEAR OLD PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THREE AND I LIVE IN
FRANCISCO I BEENA CALL OF LIFE
BUT GREAT. FOR THREE. I THANK.
LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN THE BOARD
ACCOUNT FOR A LICENSE MIDWIFE
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR PER
TO. NECK PLEASE. THANKS IS A
LINE NUMBER NINE YEAR OLD GO
AHEAD PLEASE- MORNING. DAVID
PRESIDENT OF CAL SO OF LIFE WHY.
THANK YOU FOR OPPORTUNITY HI
I'M NOT. COMMENT THREE ON ONE
OF THEM SPECIAL WELCOME TO THE
DOCTOR. TODAY LIKE YOU MEN ONE
OF THE MAIN THE ONLY OKAY WITH
THE STATE. NOT REGULATED BY THE
AMENDMENT UPON NUMBER OF THE
YEARS SECTOR THAT THEY. IF UP
THE MEDICAL FOR BY BYE. FIND
COMFORT STAFF. LATER ON A
PARTICULAR DAHLE. THE MARKET
RIGHT FROM THE INEQUALITY. I
DON'T THINK THERE'S STRUCTURE
ADDITIONAL LIKE WHY PORT BEFORE
ISSUING AFFECTED THE PROFIT
REGULATIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ALL. CALIFORNIA LOOK OKAY LIKE
MIDDLE LONG ADVOCATED FOR MY
WIFE FOR OUR NINE GUARDING LAST.
ACTIVE CORRECTIVE PRACTICES
UNDER THE DOCTOR NEVER THOUGHT
REP HELLO PUBLIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LIKE THE MEDICAL FOR
BY THE BY WILL. OMITTED THE
REGULATION AND THE FRONT THE
MALL PROFESSION THE DEFENSE.
PROF THE COMP. INN IS THEIR- IN
OUR UP REPORT THANK. REVENUE BE
ANALYZED LEVINE. THEIR CLEARLY
SHOWS THAT A LIFE NUMBER.
WELCOME ARE. ACTIVE REPORT
PRACTICES FREEDOM SUFFICIENT
NATION AND ARE INCORRECT
CONFLICT. WHAT MY WIFE THANK
FOR THE INVITE BYE- WOULD ASK
YOU TO WRAP UP AND TO SUBMIT
YOUR WRITTEN PRESENTATION TO
OUR COMMITTEES FOR
CONSIDERATION DURING THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS SO PLEASE WRAP
UP IF YOU CAN. YES I WILL WRAP
UP- THE LATE SAMPLE OF
REGULATORY CONFLICT WITH THE
PROPOSAL BY A CONTACT IN A
FURTHER LIMITS LIKE MIDWIFE SO
I THINKING UP THE LIFE BY
PRACTICE THAT. AT. TWELVE
THIRTY W. DOCTORS MEDLOCK. SB
TWELVE SEVEN ONLINE. BASE NURSE
MIDWIFERY CARE THAT- MODELS
THAT BUDGET. EIGHT OKAY THE
TELECOM BUT THE ANTITHETICAL TO
THE FINAL PRE ABILITY WITH
MODEL CARE. BUT PEOPLE ARE I
WANT MY GONNA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND FOR THOSE ON THE LINE
IF YOU HAVE WRITTEN COMMENTS
PLEASE JUMP TO THE END AND
SUBMIT THE WRITTEN COMMENTS
THAT WILL AID IN MOVING THIS
HEARING FORWARD NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IS
FOR ONLINE NUMBER NINETEEN YEAR
OLD FROM FISCAL. HI MY NAME IS
TREAT THE MCLEAN I'M A LICENSED
MIDWIFE WITHIN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA I'M ALSO A MIDWIFERY-
CLIENTS AND HAD TO BE BACK AT
HOME BECAUSE I WAS NOT ABLE TO.
HEAR THE ACCENT CARE- FOR A
HOSPITAL BIRTH AT THE TIME OF
MY CHILD BIRTH- I SUPPORT AND
HOPE THAT YOU APPROVED LANGUAGE
TO INCLUDE TO INCLUDE A
LICENSED MIDWIFERY BOARD-
INDEPENDENT REVIEW THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. ACTUALLY
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MICHELLE
MONSERRAT ROBINSON I'M WE
CONSUMER WATCHDOG I BECAME A
STATEWIDE AND NATIONAL
ADVOCATES ON THE TRAGIC DEATH
OF MY HUSBAND TO BE LIKE
MONSTER. WOULD GUIDE YOU THE
SURGICAL ERRORS UNTREATED
INFECTION AND SEPSIS I
DISCOVERED THAT HIS SURGEON HAD
A LONG ARREST RECORDS FOR
POSSESSION OF CRACK COCAINE AND
PROSECUTION I WOULD ONE OF
THOSE CONSUMERS THAT ADVOCATED
FOR THE END OF THE OLD POSITION
DIVERSION PROGRAM. WOULD
MONSTER THAT IS THE REASON WHY
THE DIFFERENT STANDARDS
RECESSES THAT USING HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS ARE IN PLACE FOR
THE LAW FIRM BY THE GOVERNOR IF
YOU THOUSAND EIGHT UNIFORM
STANDARDS ARE NOT NITPICKING
DOCTORS YEAH THEY AREONE OF
THE RARE CONSUMER PROTECTION
BETTER SAVING CALIFORNIANS FROM
A TRAGIC DEATH LIKE LLOYD IN TO
WORK. UNIFYING STANDARDS NOT
ONLY PROTECT CONSUMERS PROTECT
DOCTORS THAT REALLY WANTED AND
THEIR SUBSTANCE ABUSE THE SAME
THEIR LIVES AND THE LIVES OF
THEIR PATIENTS PLEASE
PROTECTING A FROM STANDARD TO
SAVE THE LIVES OF DOCTORS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AN AVERAGE
CALIFORNIA. WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TO SAVE LIVES WE CAN
DO THIS BY IMPLEMENTING A
PUBLIC MEMBER MAJORITY WE NEED
TO INTERNET COST RECOVERY
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ARE
COUNTING ON YOU TO OVER HARD
THIS BOARD AND REBUILD THAT
TRUST THANK YOU THANK. YOU BACK
PLEASE. THANKS A LOT NUMBER FOR
FIVE OLD COMPUTER GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN WITH. I
MANY TO CAP PERCENT EVERY MY
CARE FOR MY FOR IN BIRTH AND GO
HEALTH. AND I'M LIKE THAT THE
COMMITTEE THAT LIKE IN THE FACT
THAT REVIEW. TO FOR A LIE AND
MIDWIFE BOARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. LINE
EIGHTY TWO IS GONNA. HI MY NAME
IS TANYA MCCRACKEN I LIVE IN
MENTONE CALIFORNIA AND
UNLIMITED FREE CONSUMER AND
URGING THE LEGISLATURE TO
INCLUDE LANGUAGE IN THE MEDICAL
BOARD SENT THAT REFUSAL TO
CREATE AN INDEPENDENT LICENSE
MIDWIFE BOARD. INCREASED
PROTECTION FOR MIDWIFERY
CONSUMERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. THANKS THE LINE
NUMBER FORTY THREE YEAR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO PLEASE
PROCEED. HELLO THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS MERION CALLING FOR
ECONOMIC PATIENT SAFETY
ADVOCATE I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COMMENT BY WILLIAM PACIFICA
REGARDING MAKING THE
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS MORE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE WELL
THAT SOUNDS GREAT IT DOES HINT
AT THE BOARD'S ATTEMPTING TO
CURB IMPORTS SPENT TO SAVE
MONEY IF YOU REMEMBER THE LAST
TIME THAT HEARING MR PACIFICA
MENTIONS THE BOARD DIDN'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO INVESTIGATE MORE
CASES. CURRENTLY AGREE JUST
CASES ARE BEING ALLOWED TO BE
DOWN TO REPRIMANDS TO AVOID
MORE EXPENSIVE HEARING
PROCESSES THIS INCLUDES SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT CASES MATERNAL
DEATHS AND INFANT DEATHIN
CHILDBIRTH THREE MANY CASES TO
SAVE MONEY BECAUSE CONSUMERS AT
RISK AND FAIL TO UPHOLD THE
BOARD OF CONSUMER SAFETY ALSO
I'D LIKE TO SUGGEST THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE CHANGED THE MAKEUP
OF THE BOARD TO THE PUBLIC
MEMBERS MAKE UP THE MAJORITY.
WOULD AVOID THE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST A DOCTOR MAJORITY OF
THE BOARD CURRENTLY HAS
EXPECTED SENDS A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS ARE ALSO ACTIVE WITH
THE TMA INCLUDING TWO FORMER
CMA PRESIDENT ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT LEGISLATORS SHOULD
CONSIDER IS HAVING THE
DISCIPLINE DOCTORS HE FIRED OR
HELPING THEM HEY AT LEAST PART
OF THE COST OF THE BOARD
INVESTIGATION OTHER STATES DO
THIS AND DO NOT HAVE FINANCIAL
DEFICIT. IT'S INCLUDES FLORIDA
AND GEORGIA THIS STEP WOULD
HELP EASE THE FINANCIAL. BURDEN
ON THE MEDICAL BOARD. BOB IN
CLOSING I URGE YOU TO THE
MATTER WORK. PUBLIC MEMBER TO
ENSURE THE IS PROTECT I'LL
CHARGE YOU WITH AN- THAT. PLAN
TO MAKE THE BOY MORE FISH AND-
DIDN'T RESULT BECAUSE CONSUMER.
BEING DROPPED OR- IN IN- ORDER
TO SAVE MONEY THANK YOU FOR
ABOUT SNACKS PLEASE. WILL BE
ONLINE FOUR ONE OLD PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ERICA WITH
THE THEY LEAGUE THE MEDICAL
BOARD BEEN IN THE BILL FOR IN
ONE FORMER FOR- OVER IT AND- IF
ANYONE ELSE CURIOUS WHY THERE'S
HAVE SUCH. PROBLEMS AND WHY
NOTHING EVER CHANGES FROM WHAT
I CAN TELL THE STATE AUDITOR
HAS NEVER AUDITED THE BOARD AND
THAT IS WAY OVERDUE THE BOARD
ISN'T BEING A 100% TRUTHFUL
WITH YOU SO HOW CAN YOU DECIDE
TO GRANT FOUR MORE YEARS
WITHOUT ALL THE INVESTIGATIVE
INFORMATION. IT'S BECAUSE OF
THEIR DISHONESTY DISHONESTY
INVESTORS MISDIRECTION BUT
NOTHING EVER CHANGES OR
IMPROVES WHILE THE BOARD ALWAYS
PUNCTUATE THEIR MISSION
STATEMENT OF CONSUMER SAFETY
THAT'S NOT THEIR MISSION IN
PRACTICE WHICH IS PROVEN BY
THEIR DOUBLE 4% DISCIPLINARY
RATE AND THE FACT THAT 96% OF
THE CONSUMER COMPLAINTS THEY
RECEIVE ARE CLOSED. WITHOUT
INVESTIGATION REMEMBER THAT
THEY WERE CAUGHT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO LITERALLY THROWING
COMPLAINT IN THE TRASH THE
BOARD WAIT A LOT OF MONEY AND
THAT'S WHY AN AUDIT BY THE
STATE AUDITOR THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION IS BEYOND NECESSARY.
FOR INSTANCE THEY HAVE
QUARTERLY MEETINGS IN DIFFERENT.
CITIES AROUND THE STATE BUT
THEY ONLY. WHAT'S PRECLUDES THE
PUBLIC FROM ATTENDING. THE
SANDY HOTEL THEY USED BEEN
DOLLARS A DAY PARKING WE
REQUESTED FACILITIES BUT IT
FALLS ON DEAF EARS SOMEONE ALSO
NEEDS TO AUDIT THE BOARD
MEMBERS PER DIEM AS BOARD
MEMBERS ARE CHARGING WAY MORE
THAN OTHERS WHEN I GET A PUBLIC
RECORDS REQUEST FOR
DOCUMENTATION THEY ILLEGALLY
SENT ME INFORMATION OTHER THAN
WHAT I ASKED FOR AND THEN
STOPPED RESPONDING WHEN I TOLD
THEM IT WAS NOT WHAT WAS
REQUESTED. THEY CLEARLY DON'T
WANT ME TO BE ABLE TO PROVE
THEIR GUARDIAN BEING MISUSED
AGAIN AN AUDIT IS CRUCIAL SO WE
CAN NARROW DOWN ALL THE WAY AT
THE MEDICAL BOARD IS PULLING
THE WOOL OVER THE LEGISLATORS
AND THE PUBLIC BY THEY ARE NOT
BEING TRUTHFUL WITH YOU
LEGISLATORS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANKS FOR
GOING TO LINE FIFTY. TO GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SHANNON
BERNARD A LICENSED MIDWIVES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND FONTANA
I'M ALSO- HALF MIDWIFERY CLIENT
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF CREATING
A LICENSE NUMBER THREE BOARD SO
I CAN SPEND WIFE CAN HAVE THE
SAME SELF DETERMINATION THAT
EVERY OTHER HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONAL HOUSE IN THE
STATE. OF WELL AS OTHER STATES
HAVE IMPLEMENTED A SEPARATE
BOARD FOR LICENSED MIDWIVES-
I'M ASKING THAT LANGUAGE WOULD
BE INCLUDED IN THE SUNSET
REVIEW PAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. BURKE CERVANTES
CHAIRS LINE TEN IS GOING TO ONE
WHICH. HI THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME I'M CAROLYN WINTERS AND
I'M CALLING IN TO ASK THE BILL
LANGUAGE CREATING A LICENSED
MIDWIFE BOARD BE INCLUDED IN
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
SUNSET REVIEW GO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. LINE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD AND PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWENTY FOUR YOU MIGHT BE
MUTED. HEY CAN YOU HEAR ME
PERFECTLY LET'S GO. PLEASE
PROCEED HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS PETER WALKED INTO NON
MCCARTY PUBLIC NAME ON THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA I
DON'T WANT TO IN THE COMMITTED
TO A MISTAKE THAT I MADE BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE IN THE
TWO THIRTY ONE WELL COST
RECOVERY WAS ELIMINATED FROM
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
WOULD FORCE ME TO KEEP. CALL
COULD NOT BE AS YOU KNOW WE THE
SAME TO IN THE IN. ARSENAL READ
MORE. AND THE REMOVAL OF THE-
INTO THE BASE TOPIC OKAY AND
TO. ALSO YEARS ON THE SMALL THE
RESULTS. THE MIDDLE BOARD
ENFORCEMENT CHANNEL THIS CALL
UP. THE BORDER. SOLVING DUE TO
EXTRA HIGH FOR EXTEND. BY FORTY
BECAUSE THE SMALL. CLAIMS
PORTIONS COMES UP WITH CREATIVE
DISAPPEAR OF THE MEN'S. THAT
FROM THE- THIS OF THE LINE THEY
DON'T CALL PUBLIC IT COME ON
BECOME THE NORM SUCH NOT. EVEN
FOR GOOD CAL HAS. BEEN SWING
SEASONS ARE MADE DOCTOR INCOME
AND BUDGET NOT PUBLIC. IN MIND.
BOB SOCKS WOULD HAVE YOU TO.
NOT JUST WITH THE TOP ALL DAY
LOS USUALLY. IN THE DECENT TO
STOP THIS TO TEACHING. THEY ARE
ASKED THIS BECAUSE TO.
CHASSIDIC. THE TO A MUNCHING
BETWEEN. HAND ALL. BEFORE THE
MANY TO THAT. THE PRODUCT OF
ALL THE- AMOUNT OF BOARD ALL
COME. THE STORE IT SEEMS. TO I
URGE YOU TO READ COSTA RICA AND
A LITTLE ITS COME TO AS OF PER
MEASURES. PRIEST US THE POP.
TENDS FOR YOU NEXT PLEASE. OKAY
THANK YOU IT WAS RICHARD WILL
GO TO LAW NUMBER SEVENTY SIX
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN A MEMBER DENNIS FROM
OUR BEHALF OF THE CAL MEDICAL
SUB- BUT I THINK COMMITTEE FOR
ALL HARDWARE AND TO APPLY MY-
IN COLLEAGUES WORK. SUNDOWN IF
YOU L. SHE MADE VERY COMPELLING
WITH THE PEOPLE ON THE JOB
RATHER AS- RELATED SMALL.
BILLING MEDICARE. BEING ABLE TO
THAT THE A AND THE TASTE ON
YOUR FINAL POINT AMONG OTHER
ISSUE. OTHER JOSH THE PEOPLE
HAS MAJOR CHALLENGE TO GET CARE
TO REDUCE. OF ACCESS IN RURAL
AND COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OF THE
ISSUES HAVE TO COME A TICKET
LOOK AT THE L. A. RIVER ACT.
CREATING STRUCK CLOSER NOT
LEAVE. CHALLENGE ADDITIONALLY
UNDERSTOOD THE NEED FOR A
REASON FEE HOW. I A LEDGER COME
BUT I APPROPRIATE INCREASE
WOULD BE. STAND OUT INFORMED BY.
REVIEW OF CORPORATE OF THE AND
WHAT THOSE FROM SHOULD BE AND
HOW THE- FEE INCREASE CAN
SUPPORT THOSE KERR. WE ALSO NOW
ON HOW THE MANY QUARTERS REST
THE FISHING. HAVE AFFECTED THE
REQUIRE IF YOU- THE MEDICAL HAS
ONE OF THE HIGHEST LIKE EACH
MONTH IT MEDICAL AMONG HELP.
WITHIN CAL. I'D LIKE TO GET
SPEECH CONSERVE AS A BARRIER TO
ATTRACTING POSITION THE MOBILE.
CALIFORNIA FINALLY WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAINTAIN THE
CURRENT MAKE UP OF. THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANKS LINE NUMBER SO SIX
PROJECT ONE AT. SIX HI MY NAME
IS SHUBH. AND I LIVE IN CENTRAL.
AND ALLOW MIDWIFE AND I WAS ON
A MIDWIFERY. I WOULD LOVE FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE
LANGUAGE IN THE CENTER OF THE
BILL FORMALIZED THAT WOULD FREE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANK MISTER SHE LINE TWO YOUR
OPEN TO GO AHEAD. HELLO AND MY
NAME IS SHAMIL AND I LIVE IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND I'M CALLING
IN TO ASK LANGUAGE CREATING A
LICENSE MCCARTY FORD BE
INCLUDED AND THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA SUNSET REVIEW
BATTLE. THE FORMATION OF A
LICENSED MIDWIFE BOARD IS
FOUNDATIONAL TO ENSURING THAT
LICENSE ADVISOR CAN PRACTICE
INDEPENDENTLY AS THEY ARE
INTENDED TO DO IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY COMPETENT
SKILLED PROVIDERS MANAGING LOW
RISK PREGNANCIES. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY AN OUT
LIAR AND THAT THERE ISN'T
ALREADY A LICENSED MIDWIFE
BOARD ESTABLISHED AND I URGE
YOU TO LOOK BEYOND CALIFORNIA
AND TWO OTHER STATE WHICH
POPULATION CHERTHALA HOSPITAL
MIDWIFE AND WHICH HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF MIDWIVES WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY ACTIVELY BY WAY OF AN
INDEPENDENT LIFE. THANKS FOR.
IT FATHER. SEVERAL BOARD AND
EVERY TYPE HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
CAL HAS THEIR OWN I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER WHY MADE BY CAL WHAT
THE LAW HISTORY PROVIDING
EXCELLENT CARE TO FAMILIES DO
NOT HAVE THEIR OWN LICENSE
PLATE BOARD ALREADY. ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANKS A LOT NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PUT YOUR
LANDLORD YEAH. LINE FIFTY
EIGHT. YES IF YOU GO AHEAD
PLEASE- EXCELLENT. MY NAME IS
ANDREA HAD STRAM AND I AM
CALLING IS SOMEONE WHO HAS
RECEIVED A FREE CARE FOR
PREGNANCIES AND BIRTHS. BY BOTH
CERTIFIED NURSE MIDWIVES AND
LICENSED MIDWIVES INCLUDING A GIVING BIRTH AT HOME
MYSELF. OPAL TIME AND SINCE
GOVERNMENT IS ABOUT THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE WHEN I HEAR THE
PEOPLE SAYING IS THEY SUPPORT
THAT THE LANGUAGE OF CREATING A
LICENSED MIDWIFERY BOARD BE
INCLUDED IN THE SUNSET REVIEW
BILL SO PLEASE DO THAT AND JUST
AS AN ASIDE I FEEL COMPELLED TO
SAY BUT I FIND IT QUITE
CONCERNING THAT YOU SENATORS
SEEM TO THINK THAT YOU NEED TO
RUSH OUT OF THERE BY NOON ONE
SUCH IMPORTANT TESTIMONY IS
BEING GIVEN BY THE PUBLIC
REMEMBER WE THE PEOPLE NOT. THE
GOVERNMENT WE HAVE A RIGHT TO
SPEAK WHETHER YOU THINK YOU
pTHANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL NOTE
FOR THE RECORD THAT I HAVE NOT
LIMITED ANY PUBLIC TESTIMONY
THAT'S BEEN PRESENTED TODAY OR
FRANKLY ANY OTHER HEARING
BEFORE THE SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS OF THE TWO. LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES THANK. YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE GOING ON THE
LINE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD OF THE UNITED. THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- COMMITTEES- MY
NAME IS RANDALL. IS A
PSYCHIATRIC POSITIONS ALLIANCE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE
JACKSON SAID BUCKLEY TO THE
MEDICAL BOARDS OF SPEAKING HOW
GRANTED AUTHORITY TO OBTAIN.
PSYCHOTHERAPY RECORDS VIA
SUBPOENA EVEN WITHOUT PATIENT
CONSENT- PSYCHOTHERAPIES
DEPENDED ON THE PORCH
REVELATION OF THE MOST INTIMATE
AND EMBARRASSING DETAILS IN A
PATIENT'S LIFE. AND UNLESS
SUCH. INFORMATION CAN BE HELD
IN THE UTMOST CONFIDENCE
PATIENTS ARE GOING TO BE
RELUCTANT TO MAKE PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER AND DIAGNOSIS TREATMENT
AND ULTIMATELY SUCCESSFUL
TREATMENT. DEPENDS ON THEIR
THANK. YOU THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOUAND THIS WILL
NUMBER SEVEN GO AHEAD YOU'RE
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS QUINCY BABY I'M A LICENSED
MIDWIFE I LIVE IN YUCCA VALLEY
IN SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY I ALSO
HAVE RECEIVED MIDWIFERY CARE
FOR MY PREGNANCY AND BIRTH A
SUCCESSFUL LEAD BACK AT HOME
AFTER TO SIT THERE IN. I AM
REQUESTING THAT THE COMMITTEES
INCLUDE LANGUAGE IN THE SUNSET
REVIEW BOARD TO FORMALIZE HIS
MIDWIFE BOARD IN ORDER TO
BETTER PROTECT THE PUBLIC WHO
CHOOSE MIDWIFERY CARE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NEXT IN LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANGELA YES I'M HERE MY NAME IS
ANJALI CITATION BURKE I LIVE IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING
IN EFFORTS TO IMPROVE MATERNAL
HEALTH CARE ON OUR PATIENTS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CHOICES AND
IMPROVE ACCESS TO MIDWIFERY
CARE. I MYSELF WITH EACH BASED
MIDWIFERY CARE DURING THE BIRTH
OF MY CHILD AND PROVIDED AS A
LICENSE THAT'S WHY I'M CALLING
IN TO ASK THAT LANGUAGE
CREATING A LICENSED MIDWIFE
BOARD INCLUDED AND THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA SUNSET
REVIEW BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT TIME WE GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINETY EIGHT YOU'RE
WELCOME PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ANDREA MEYER AND
INTENDED TO GO BUT BEFORE I
MOVED HERE I LIVED IN PASADENA
AND LOS ANGELES I HAD MY FIRST
HOME REPAIR. IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE BEFORE BY STEPHEN HAD
LICENSES IT WAS SO GREAT AND I
FELT SO SAFE THAT I WENT ON TO
BECOME A LICENSED MIDWIFE
MYSELF. ANSWERED HUNDREDS OF. I
IT AND I'VE HAD TWO MORE HOME
BURKE AND I AM REQUESTING THAT
YOU. CREATE A LIFE WITH NETWORK
MIDWIFE BOARD IN THE SUNSET
REVIEW BILL AND I THINK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AGAIN I'M IN SAN
DIEGO. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
PLEASE. HE ACTUALLY GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINETY FOUR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. MY NAME IS.
ERIN ON THE LINE. SACRAMENTO
FIGHTER AND I THINK THAT YOU
CAN WORK- ACCORDING OF A LIGHT.
FILLED IN FOR. THEY DON'T LIVE
BY ONE. BY COMMUNITY AND IN IS
ALL OVER YEAH THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT PLEASE
SILENCE SEVENTY IS OPEN PLEASE
GO ONLINE SEVENTY. YES ME SORRY
HI MY NAME IS KATIE DEALER I AM
ALSO A LICENSED MIDWIFE AND
PRACTICING IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
I HAVE ATTENDED OVER SIX
HUNDRED BURKE WITH EXCELLENT
OUTCOMES YOU CAN LOOK ME UP ON
THE MEDICAL BOARD WEBSITE. I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO KEEP TRACK OF
OUR NUMBERS ON THE COMPLAINT
AGAINST US AND THEY ARE VERY
LOW COMPARED WITH THE VISION.
AND EVEN CRITICALLY BY THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EACH YEAR I'D
ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT WE
HAVE VERY EXCELLENT OUTCOMES
SPECIFICALLY AND YOU CAN FIND
US ONLINE BY THIRTEEN WE HAVE
ACTUALLY BETTER OUTCOME THAN.
MANY BRING. HOSPITAL DOCTORS-
THEN I ABSOLUTE REQUESTED THE
COMMITTEE INCLUDE LANGUAGE IN
THE FUNDS THAT REFUSAL TO FORM
A LICENSED MIDWIFE BOARD. IN
ORDER TO BETTER PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. CHOOSE MIDWIFERY CARE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
LISTENING. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
COMMENT NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND- GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS. STEVEN FUTURE VALUE TO
CALIFORNIA THE NEW FATHER AS OF
JANUARY. AND MY- WHITE.
OPTIONAL MIDWIFERY CARE HI
COMMITTEE ON THE BIRTH I'M
CALLING TO ASK THAT THE
LANGUAGE CREATING A LICENSING
WHITE BOARD BE INCLUDED IN THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IT
WOULD BE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT. NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER NIXON
ONE NUMBER NINETY NINE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
PATTERSON BRUNNER AND I'M A
RESIDENT OF BERKELEY CALIFORNIA.
MEETING MIDWIFERY CARE- FROM
LICENSED MIDWIFE SHALL APPOINT
AFTER MY PREGNANCY AND BIRTH-
I'M CALLING TO REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEES INCLUDE LANGUAGE IN
THE CONTRACT REVIEW BUILT UPON
A LICENSED MIDWIFE BOARD IN
ORDER TO BETTER PROTECT THE
PUBLIC WHO CHOOSE MIDWIFERY
CARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF WINE ONE SIXTEEN YEAR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I GUESS
THAT MEANS CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
MA'AM CLEAR LOUD AND CLEAR
PLEASE PROCEED HELLO. THANK YOU
YES MY NAME IS NOW THAT AND I
ALSO AND CALLING FROM SAN
DIEGO. AND I RECEIVED MATHIS WE
CARE FOR MY FOR TWO OF MY
PREGNANCY AND BIRTH AND- I IT
RAN- IT SECOND TIME AROUND- AND
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO REQUEST
THAT THE COMMITTEE INCLUDE
LANGUAGE IN THE CENTER OF YOUR
BILL. COULD FORM AND I THINK
THAT THE FREE BREAK IN ORDER TO
BETTER PROTECT. EVERYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE WITH A MIDWIFE.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
THEN THE NEXT WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES CLEAR LEFT BLOOD CLEAR PUT
THREE. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS JOHN
REYNOLDS AND I AM A RESIDENT OF
RIVERSIDE CALIFORNIA- CAN
YOU'RE GOING TO GO TO RIVERSIDE
I NEEDED I WANTED HIM TO BE
BACK AND I HAD TO DRIVE OVER
THIRTY FIVE MILES ORANGE COUNTY
TO RECEIVE ONE BECAUSE IT WILL
BE. IN THE AREA WHAT IT YOU I'M
HEADED TO THE BUS WILL BE BACK
AFTER THAT AND THEN LAST YEAR'S
BEGINNING THE PANDEMIC- WE HAD
A WHOLE BIRD WITH AN EXCELLENT
MIDWIVES POLICIA HUBBLE HERE IN
THE AREA. AND HAS HAD A
SUCCESSFUL BEAUTIFUL HOME BURKE
WHICH WAS SO MEANINGFUL- TO
HAVE WHEN THE WORLD IS GOING
CRAZY AND THE THOUGHT OF GIVING.
BIRTH BY MYSELF- YOU KNOW WHAT
WAS REALLY. AND SO TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A LICENSE MAY BE. BOARD
TELLING. IN OUR STATE- NOT GET
IF WE HAVE ANOTHER PANDEMIC BUT
THOUGH THAT PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
AREAS LIKE I DO YOU CAN HAVE
THE OPTION. OF HAVING BIRTH
WHERE THEY WANT TO AND HOW THEY
WANT TO IN SO. PLEASE CONSIDER
ADDING LANGUAGE IN THE SUNSET
REVIEW BILL- TO FORMAL LIKE
COMPLETELY FREE BOARD IN ORDER
TO BETTER PROTECT PROTECT THE
PUBLIC- AND PER MONTH LIKE ME
WHO SHOULD MAKE REFERENCE HERE
SO THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SIGNATURE COM HAVE NOT
YET DONE SO. ONE AT THIS TIME
WE'RE NOT GOING TO LIE NUMBER
ONE TWENTY SIX YOU WANT OPEN
BORDERS PLEASE. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME LOUD AND CLEAR PLEASE
PROCEED A LOT. YES MY NAME IS
JOSE MARK TWAIN I'VE BEEN A
LICENSED MIDWIFE. IN THE
BEGINNING I'VE BEEN PRACTICING
MIDWIFERY IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
THE EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
WAS PART OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
COMMITTEE THAT- THE IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN WE WERE
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT OUR
ORIGINAL LEGISLATIVE AGENDA.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THAT WE ARE ONLY.
AID A GROUP OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD BECAUSE NO ONE COULD
AFFORD TO GIVE US AN
INDEPENDENT. FORD IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES- TO WE
SEARCHED FOR OTHER BOARDS TO BE
UNDER BUT THE MEDICAL BOARD
WITH THE ONLY ONE THAT WAS COST
EFFECTIVE SO WE ARE. REGULATED
BY THE MEDICAL BOARD NOT
BECAUSE IT IS- SOMETHING THAT
IS MEDICALLY INDICATED IT'S
ONLY BY DEFAULT AND SO GIVING
THE MEDICAL BOARD- HEARD YOU
OVER LIFE MIDWIVES DOES NOT
INCREASE SAFETY ON IT DOESN'T
INCREASE EFFICIENCY BUT IT DOES
CREATE PROBLEMS OF CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AND SO I'M URGING YOU
TO- GIVE US THE RIGHT TO FORM
OUR OWN BOARD. I'VE BEEN A
LICENSED MIDWIFE FOR AS LONG AS
THERE ARE BEEN LICENSED
MIDWIVES IN THE STATE AND I'VE
BEEN WATCHING. HOW THINGS HAVE
OVER THE YEARS SO- IT TIMELY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WE'VE TWELVE INDIVIDUALS STILL
WAITING ON THE LINE SO FOR
THOSE WAITING I WOULD ASK YOU
TO LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE. NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NEXT TO LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ARIELLE OKAY. AND
I LIVE IN SAN JOSE I HAD
RECEIVED MEDICAL CARE FOR ALL
FOUR OF MY PREGNANCIES AND HOME
BIRTH- I ALSO WORK AT THE
DEALER AND UP THE VISION
SUPPORT PEOPLE WHO ARE ALSO
CHOOSING TO BIRTH AT HOME. I'M
REQUESTING THAT THE COMMITTEE
INCLUDE LANGUAGE IN THE
COMPLETE REVIEW BILL TO
FORMALIZE THE QUITE BORED IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
RICHARD MCGRATH WE CARE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK. YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE.
ONE THIRTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY MY NAME IS
LINDA HOPKINS AND THE FIFTH
DISTRICT SUPERVISOR FOR THE
COUNTY OF SONOMA AND I
REPRESENT THE ROUGHLY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS IN
WESTERN CINEMA COUNTY HELD A
MOM OF THREE CHILDREN ALL OF
WHOM WRE DELIVERED BY MIDWIVES
AND TWO OF WHOM WERE BORN AT
HOME UNDER THE CARE OF LICENSE
MIDWAY. IN THE FIRST NUMBER
COUNTY SUPERVISOR TO GIVE BIRTH
WHILE SERVING AS AN ELECTED
SUPERVISOR AND I REALLY
APPRECIATED THE CARE OF MY
LICENSE MIDWIVES ON MY DISTRICT
WENT THROUGH A CATASTROPHIC
FLOOD WHEN MY YOUNG SON WAS
LESS THAN ONE MONTH OLD AFTER
MANY CONSTITUENTS ARE CLIENTS
OF MIDWIVES AND I WANT TO NOTE
THAT DURING OUR MANY WILDFIRE
EVENTS AND ACTIVATIONS AND
SONOMA COUNTY DURING WHICH
ENTIRE HOSPITALS WERE
EVACUATED. LICENSED MIDWIVES
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR PREGNANT
AND LABORING WOMEN FAILED TO
PROVIDE CARE TO MANY
TRADITIONALLY DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THIRD TO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT I AM CALLING IN TO
ASK THAT LANGUAGE CREATING A
LICENSED MIDWIFE BOARD BE
INCLUDED IN THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA SUNSET REVIEW
BELL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR ATTENTION.
SUPERVISORS THANK. YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. WELL I
pAHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THERESA
YOU I LIVE IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I'M BOARD
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES FOR ACCESS TO MIDWIVES
A CONSUMER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WITH OVER FIVE
THOUSAND SUPPORTERS. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT INCLUSION OF
LANGUAGE FOR THE FORMATION OF A
LICENSED MIDWIFE BILL UNDER THE
SUNSET REVIEW. THANK YOU
MIDWIVES ARE THE ONLY
HEALTHCARE PROFESSION IN
CALIFORNIA. NOT OVERSEEN BY A
BOARD OF THEIR OWN PEERS ARE
CONSUMERS. I HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF PATERNALISM AND
SEXISM THAT HAS ALMOST ENDED
THE PROFESSION OF MIDWIFERY.
AND CONTINUES TO HAVE A MALE
DOMINATED PROFESSION. ALL THE
FEMALE DOMINATED ONE WHEN HIS
PATIENTS ARE ALMOST ENTIRELY
MADE UP OF WOMEN. THE IDEA THAT
A TRAINED PROFESSIONAL WOULDN'T
KNOW WHEN TO TRANSFER CLIENTS
MEDICAL CARE IS JUST PART OF
THE PATERNALISM. THE MEDICAL
BOARD HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
ADEQUATELY OVERSEE LIKE MIDWIFE
OR MANAGE COMPLAINT. ADDITIONS
DO NOT UNDERSTAND MIDWIFERY
CARE AND THE MIDWIFERY MODEL.
THEY ARE IN FACT SCIENCE
AGAINST MIDWIFERY AND
PHYSICIANS THERE CNN A CAGR THE
VERY PROFESSION THAT IS
CURTAILING ECONOMY OF MIDWIFERY
CONSUMERS YOUR RECENT
LEGISLATION. IT IS AGAINST
PUBLIC INTEREST. FOR LIKE IT'S
BEEN LIKE TO BE CONTINUE TO BE
OVERSEEN BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
BESIDES THE NEGLECT AND
IGNORANCE OF MINISTRY IT IS
MARGINALIZING THE VOICES OF
CONSUMERS. AND MINIMALIST
LIGHTING THEIR EXPERIENCES
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
MR ONE ONE OF SIX YEAR OLD IS
GOING. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
AARON SNYDER AND I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WITH MY FAMILY WE
RECEIVED WONDERFUL MIDWIFERY
CARE FOR OUR PAST PREGNANCIES
AND ARE RECEIVING- I GET
EXCEPTIONAL CARE FOR OUR
CURRENT PREGNANCY. BUT OUR BABY
EXPECTED THIS SUMMER AND- I'M
CALLING TO ASK THAT LANGUAGE BE
INCLUDED IN THE FUNDS EVERY FEW
BUILDS UP FOR THE LICENSE PLATE
OR TO HELP SUPPORT PROTECTION
FAMILIES LIKE OURS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. HELLO
MORE. THE HOLE IN THE. ONE HI.
A QUICK CAL I AM ALL THREE OF
MY CHILDREN HOME WITH MY I AM
CALLING IN ACT THAT CREATE A
LICENSE MIDWIFE BOARD BE
INCLUDED AND THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA SUNSET REVIEW
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. WE LINE NINETY ONE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS
JESSICA SOHL MAPS AND- I LIVE
IN AN DIEGO AND I HAVE
RECEIVED MIDWIFERY CARE MY
PREGNANCY IT WAS EXCEPTIONAL
AND I'M CALLING IN TO REQUEST
THAT THE COMMITTEE INCLUDE
LANGUAGE IN THE CONTRACT REVIEW
BOARD TO FORMALIZE. BOARD IN
ORDER TO BETTER PROTECT THE
PUBLIC WHICH IS NETWORK REPAIR.
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LOCAL YOU'RE
GOING TO. HI MY NAME IS JULIE
AND I'M AND I'M A PERSON WHO
RECEIVED CARE FOR MY PREGNANCY
AND BIRTH AND I'M HOSPITAL
BIRTH. THERE'S A LOT OF OUT OF
HOSPITAL GREEN I'M ADDRESSING
THAT MANY LANGUAGES ABOUT THAT
REVIEW FELT WARM LICENSE MADE
BY FORD IN ORDER TO BETTER
PROTECT THE PUBLIC THE TWO MEN
WERE GREAT CARE. AND TO END THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST BACK.
EXCEPT IN THE CARDS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK PLEASE. PLEASE READ A
LINE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO AND-
HELLO MY NAME IS TRACY TO MAKE
IT TONIGHT ACRE. I AT THE FAIR
INJURE ACT PATIENT THAT I'M
JUST THE MEDICAL CENTRAL VALLEY
WHO. DID MY BEST TO RAISE MY
FAMILY AND YET I'M TAKING
ANOTHER MOTHER'S DAY WITHOUT MY
BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTER WHO LOST HER
LIFE. DUE TO MEDICAL
NEGLIGENCE. MY DAUGHTER WAS
POLICY AND MONITOR PREGNANCY
CLOSELY UNTIL SHE DEVELOPED A
CONDITION WHERE SHE COULDN'T
BREATHE SHE HAD A VISION
PROBLEM. THIRTEEN INTERFERE AND
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE SHE HAD
EVERY SIGN THAT THE CRIMES YEAH
BUT THOSE. PLANS WERE IGNORED
BY TWO DOCTORS. SHE TRY. BUT
YOUR REGULAR OPG WHY BUT NOT
HERE SO WE WENT TO OUR LOCAL
HOSPITAL IN NEED OF MEDICAL
CARE. FOR HER AND HER UNBORN
PLAN. WHAT WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
THAT THE HOSPITAL ON CALL
DOCTOR WAS A REPEAT OFFENDER.
THAT THE MEDICAL BOARD ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE TO PRACTICE KNOWING
THAT HE WOULD MAKE IT THAT THAT.
OTHER MOTHERS AND BABIES. THERE
WERE MANY OTHER VICTIMS BESIDE
MY DAUGHTERS. WHAT UP TO TWO
MONTHS BEFORE MY DAUGHTER'S
DEATH IN CONTRAST THE NEW YORK
MEDICAL BOARD HAS SUSPENDED. A
DOCTOR FOR HARMING MULTIPLE
WOMEN CAN'T BE IN THEIR BOARD
INVESTIGATION HOW COULD
CALIFORNIA ALLOW THE DOCTOR. TO
HARM MOTHERS AND BABIES FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. AND YET
STILL PRACTICING TODAY I KNOW
YOU HAVE HEARD MANY FAMILIES
DURING THE FIRST PART OF THE
SUNSET REVIEW BUT I REALLY NEED
YOU TO UNDERSTAND WHAT A MOTHER.
LIKE ME GO THROUGH WHEN TRYING
TO WORK WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD
I KNOW THE MEDICAL STAFF MAKES
IT APPEAR TO BE SAMPLE. BUT I
NEED YOU TO UNDERSTAND THERE'S
NO CONSUMER PROTECTION WITH
THIS BOARD NOT AT ALL. THEY
MAKE A PROFIT SO INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT. AND THEY MAKE IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO FOLLOW THE
PROCESS. THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CLAIMS THAT ONCE THE COMPLAINT
IS FILED THAT THE COMPLAINT NO
LONGER BELONGS TO THE FAMILY
WELL I'M HERE TO TELL YOU. THAT
THAT THE ACT ALONG TO THE
FAMILY. I COULD NEVER HAVE A
DIRECT DEPOSIT THE POINT.
WITHOUT HELP. THE MEDICAL BOARD
STAFF HAS LIED TO ME AND
CONSTANTLY MISLEADING ME THE
PRODUCT DOES NOT WORK FOR
FAMILY I DIDN'T MEAN HAS
ORGANIZED A CAMPAIGN WITH THE
HELP OF CONSUMER WATCHDOG TO
GET TO THE POINT THAT I KNOW.
IT'S OUT WHAT IT TAKES FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD TO GET ATTENTION
WELL IT SHOULDN'T. WE NEED A
PUBLIC MENDER MEMBER MAJORITY
ON THE BOARD. WE NEED A PUBLIC
MEMBER SO. PROBABLY MEMBER ALSO
SAID AT THE LAST MEETING THAT
WE NEED A PUBLIC MEMBER PORT.
WE NEED A- BACK OFFICE. WE
REALLY NEED YOU TO TAKE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND PUT THEM IN
THE SUNSET BUILT. OUT CHANGE
MOTHERS AND BABIES WILL
CONTINUE TO DIE. YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO ASSURE THAT THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION IS REALLY
PARAMOUNT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SURE FOR LAWSON THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE WILL
NOT ALLOW AN EIGHTY SEVEN YEAR
OLD PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S HALEY GARRETT I LIVE IN
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA. AND I'M
CALLING TO ASK THAT LANGUAGE
CREATING A LICENSED MIDWIFE OR-
AT THE INCLUDED IN THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA AND REPEAT
THAT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
NEXT PLEASE. ONE ONE TWENTY TWO
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS
ASHLEY FOR SHAT AND I LIVE IN
CONTROL ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA I
RECEIVED EXCELLENT MIDWIFERY
CARE DURING MY PREGNANCY AND
HOME BIRTH. FIVE FULLY
ANTICIPATE AND EXPECT TO HAVE
ANOTHER HOME BIRTH IN THE
FUTURE WITH EXCELLENTLY WITH
MIDWIFERY CARE AND I'M CALLING
IN TO ASK THAT LANGUAGE
CREATING A LICENSED MIDWIFE
BOARD BE INCLUDED IN THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
THAT REVIEW. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. UNLESS WE GO
TO LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY ONE
OF THE LINES OPEN. HEY GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SAMUEL I'M
CALLING FROM YOUR CALIFORNIA. I
AM A PERSON WHO RECEIVE
MIDWIFERY CARE FOR MY PREGNANCY
AND BIRTH. AND I AM REQUESTING
THAT THE COMMITMENTS OF
LANGUAGE IN THE SENSE THAT
REVIEW BILL TO FORM A LICENSED
MIDWIFE BOARD IN ORDER TO
BETTER PROTECT THE PUBLIC WHICH
IS MADE BY THREE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK
RICHARD MOSTLY ONLINE ONE OH
THREE FOUR THREE ZERO POINT. HI
MY NAME IS CAITLYN KIRKMAN AND
I'M A LICENSED MIDWIFE
PRACTICING IN CINEMA COUNTY AND
I ENORMOUSLY SUPPORT LIKE
MIDWIVES HAVING THEIR LICENSING
BOARD. ELIMINATE THE ENORMOUS
CONFLICT OF INTEREST THAT IS TO
BE LIKE UNDER THE MEDICAL BOARD
THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
TIME THANK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. MR SURELY
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS INTO
THE SUN THANK YOU MR MURRAY-
WE'VE HEARD PUBLIC TESTIMONY
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS. REGARDING THE
ISSUES BEFORE US INVOLVING THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. I
SEE NONE SO COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
TODAY CHAIR LOW THANK YOU ANY
FINAL COMMENTS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK. OUR WITNESSES IN
THE MEDICAL BOARD PERSONNEL FOR
THE TESTIMONY TODAY AND MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC FOR SHARING THEIR
STORIES AND WEIGHING IN ON
THESE PROCEEDINGS AND THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE CONSIDERING.
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
WHERE YOU WISH TO DO THIS
ANYWAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. OR THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE FOR BOTH
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU AND WE PARTICIPATE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU EVERYONE WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA TODAY THE JOINT
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IS
ADJOURNED.